Hey, gang, welcome to Smart List. We are a sweet new podcast starring myself, Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman, and Will Arnett, and we are complete idiots. So what we do is we bring on a guest, and we ask them stuff, and they make us smarter. Hopefully. It's super cool. So please, come with us and enjoy the show. All by yourself, you got to find your own food, make your own shelter, you have 10 items
嘿，伙计们，欢迎来到《Smart List》。这是一个很棒的新播客，由我本人肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）、杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）和威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）主演，我们都是彻头彻尾的白痴。所以我们要做的是请来一位嘉宾，问他们一些问题，然后让他们让我们变得更聪明。希望如此。这真的很酷。所以请加入我们，享受这个节目。你得独自一人，自己找食物，自己搭建住所，你有10件物品
you can take into the wild with you, and you're all by yourself. You got to film the whole thing. Wait, where's this? It's a survival show called Alone that I am super addicted to right now, and it's also making our situation seem pretty luxe. You know what, how hilarious that you're addicted to a show that's called Alone. Yeah. Well, you know, it's making me feel better about the fact that you want to be alone all
你可以带进荒野，而且你完全是一个人。你得把整个过程都拍下来。等等，这是什么？这是一个叫《Alone》的生存节目，我现在超级上瘾，而且它让我们的处境看起来相当奢华。你知道吗，你对一个叫《Alone》的节目上瘾真是太搞笑了。是啊。嗯，你知道，这让我对你一直想独处的事实感觉好受了一些。
the time. It makes you feel like you have company. Now, yeah, these people have serious introvert problems. Mine's more functional. Wait, babe, and be honest, did you start coronavirus just so that you could be alone? So I could wear these plaid PJ pants for four months straight? Oh, God, I smell so bad. Jason, do you like being alone, or do you like being around around here?
这让你觉得你还有伴。现在，是的，这些人有严重的内向问题。我的更具功能性。等等，宝贝，说实话，你发起新冠疫情是不是就为了能一个人待着？这样我就能连续四个月穿这条格子睡裤了？哦，天哪，我身上味道太难闻了。杰森，你喜欢独处，还是喜欢待在这里？
I am. I'm a full-blown introvert. But I mean, I'll come on out and party like the rest of them, but I need to go back inside and refill my tank. Do you think it's because you've been around people all your life, just surrounded by people constantly your whole life? Well, I don't think so, although I bet you if I was honest and I was sitting on the land down on the couch in the doctor's office, I'd probably say that a portion of my introvertness
我是。我是个彻头彻尾的内向者。但我的意思是，我会出来像其他人一样聚会，但我需要回到室内给我的能量槽充电。你觉得这是因为你一生都围绕在人们身边，一直被人群包围吗？嗯，我不这么认为，尽管我敢打赌，如果我诚实一点，坐在医生办公室的沙发上，我可能会说我内向的一部分
is a bit of a stay away from me mechanism. I want my boundaries up and my privacy and all that crap. What do you think it is that you're hiding about yourself? We're rolling, right? Dr. I am. Here's the thing, you want to talk about hiding. This is a perfect segue into introducing our guest this week.
是一种“离我远点”的机制。我想要建立界限，保护我的隐私，诸如此类的废话。你觉得你在隐藏关于自己的什么？我们在录音，对吧？医生。我是。问题是，你想谈论隐藏。这正好引出了我们这周的嘉宾。
This is a person who has been hiding in plain sight for a long time. It's very difficult for this person actually to hide because they demand a lot of attention, not only because of their physical appearance and because of their size, but also because of their, well, you'll see, this person, I remember we've said before, this person needs no introduction. Shaquille Neal. I refuse to give this person an introduction because you know who this person is, they're very, very well known, I hate to say talented because it makes me mad to say that this person
这是一个长期隐藏在众目睽睽之下的人。这个人其实很难隐藏，因为他们需要很多关注，不仅是因为他们的外表和体型，还因为他们的……好吧，你会看到的，这个人，我记得我们之前说过，这个人不需要介绍。沙奎尔·尼尔（Shaquille Neal）。我拒绝给这个人做介绍，因为你知道这个人是谁，他们非常、非常出名，我讨厌说有才华，因为说这个人
is talented. Shakira. Is it Shakira? Is it Shakira? It's so close to Shakira. It's so close. Babylonia. Yeah, almost as good a dancer as Shakira.
有才华让我很生气。夏奇拉（Shakira）。是夏奇拉吗？是夏奇拉吗？离夏奇拉很近。非常近。巴比伦尼亚（Babylonia）。是啊，跳舞跳得几乎和夏奇拉一样好。
This person was once known for doing a dance that was involved kind of like a string attached to their waist and they would kind of do this like dumb thing with their pockets. It was like the dumbest dance. Oh, no. Guess what? This week. This is Conan O'Brien. Oh, people, Mr. Conan O'Brien.
这个人曾经因为跳一种舞而出名，那种舞涉及一种系在腰间的绳子，他们会用口袋做那种愚蠢的动作。那是史上最蠢的舞。哦，不。猜猜怎么着？这周。这是柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）。哦，伙计们，柯南·奥布莱恩先生。
Oh, man. I got it. Yeah. I got it. Look at him. He got us close. Oh, man. Yes.
哦，天哪。我做到了。是的。我做到了。看看他。他让我们很接近了。哦，天哪。是的。
Just under the wire. Yes. Do you like sitting there and listening to us before you come on? Are you like, let's just get this over with? I thought there was some time wasting. We'll tighten it up later. I didn't need to hear Jason go on for, I think, 11 minutes about his current favorite reality show that he's binging.
就在最后一刻。是的。你喜欢在我们上场前坐在那里听我们说话吗？你是不是在想，让我们赶紧结束吧？我觉得这有点浪费时间。我们稍后再把它收紧。我不需要听杰森花，我想是11分钟，谈论他目前正在狂看的真人秀节目。
I am long winded. That is some of my life. I'll never get back. But now you've got a real tasty new show to watch. I know you're looking for things to do with all your free time. I binge watch my show. That's what I do in my spare time. Repeat.
我说话啰嗦。那是我生活的一部分。我永远也回不去了。但现在你有一个真正美味的新节目可以看了。我知道你在寻找打发空闲时间的事情做。我狂看我的节目。这就是我业余时间做的事。重复。
Repeat. You know what's really funny? If you guys came over and it doesn't even have to be because I have a back catalog, I just save a lot of them on, you know, I record them. So you come over to my house at any time that I'm here, you'll hear a loud laughing, and you'd come up to my room and you'd see me watching my show from 2004. Right. Say, did you hear what I just said?
重复。你知道什么真的很有趣吗？如果你们过来，甚至不需要是因为我有过往剧集，我只是把它们存了很多，你知道，我录下来了。所以你随时来我家，只要我在家，你就会听到大声的笑声，你会走到我的房间，看到我在看我2004年的节目。对。说，你听到我刚才说的了吗？
Yeah. Get in here. The kids are all tied up in there and everybody's just forced to watch. If you want any more iPad time, you have to watch Daddy's show. I do. I will say once, it's a true story. I was once skiing somewhere out west, not west of where we are now. Let's not get into that.
是的。进来吧。孩子们都被绑在那里，每个人都被迫观看。如果你想要更多使用iPad的时间，你就得看爸爸的节目。我确实这么做。我得说有一次，这是一个真实的故事。我曾经在西部某个地方滑雪，不是我们现在所在位置的西边。我们别纠结那个了。
You know what I mean? Is that what we're going to do? We're going to cut in. Okay. We don't care. We're not going to judge you for going to Deer Park. Deer Valley. You mean?
你知道我的意思吗？这就是我们要做的吗？我们要插话吗？好吧。我们不在乎。我们不会因为你去鹿园（Deer Park）而评判你。你是说鹿谷（Deer Valley）吗？
Yeah. Deer Valley. Deer Park. What an idiot. Yeah. I went to the park where you can look at deer. Stupid ass. What a great park that would be.
是的。鹿谷。鹿园。真是个白痴。是啊，我去了那个可以看鹿的公园。蠢货。那会是个多么棒的公园啊。
How's our deer park doing? Not so good. Again, nobody came to look at the deer. Let me tell you this story. So I'm skiing with my family in Deer Valley and then I hear someone say, dude, Colbert is on the other, Stephen Colbert is on the other slope. You guys must be here together. And I said, no.
我们的鹿园怎么样了？不太好。同样，没人来看鹿。让我告诉你这个故事。所以我和家人在鹿谷滑雪，然后我听到有人说，伙计，科尔伯特（Colbert）在另一边，斯蒂芬·科尔伯特（Stephen Colbert）在另一条坡道上。你们一定是一起来的。我说，不。
And they just assume that talk show hosts call each other and make a plan. But anyway, then shortly afterwards I get a text from Stephen Colbert saying, I hear everyone says that a tall Belgian woman who looks like you is here. I immediately said, yes, I'm here. So we ski together and we ski for a bit. And at one point, the two of us, and we're skiing with his kids who are great, his family, his kids are now much older now. This story took a few years old, but his kids are now, I think, in their fifties.
他们就以为脱口秀主持人们会互相打电话并制定计划。但无论如何，不久之后我收到斯蒂芬·科尔伯特的短信说，我听说每个人都说一个长得像你的高个子比利时女人在这里。我立刻说，是的，我在这里。所以我们一起滑雪，滑了一会儿。在某个时刻，我们俩，我们和他的孩子们一起滑雪，他们很棒，他的家人，他的孩子们现在大多了。这个故事已经过去几年了，但他的孩子们现在，我想，已经五十多岁了。
Thanks for bringing on the old stories. Sorry. But anyway, we're on the ski lift together, just the two of us. And it's deadly quiet. And then he starts telling me a story about how when his show comes on, he goes in the other room while his wife and his kids watch it. And he was like, and then I hear them laugh. And then we talk about the show afterwards.
谢谢你带来这些老故事。抱歉。但无论如何，我们在滑雪缆车上，只有我们俩。死一般的寂静。然后他开始给我讲一个故事，说当他的节目播出时，他会去另一个房间，而他的妻子和孩子们在看。他说，然后我听到他们笑。然后我们之后会讨论这个节目。
And I thought, my kids and my wife have never watched my show. It's the last thing in the world anybody wants to do. No, they will watch my show if I say, if one of their heroes is on, and I say, oh, Lin Manuel Miranda was on the show or an ads on the show, whatever, no, no, yeah, whatever. And, you know, and then they'll watch that much of it. And they'll really pay attention to the other person talking. They have no interest in watching my show. And I think that's very helpful.
我想，我的孩子们和我的妻子从来没看过我的节目。这是世界上任何人最不想做的事。不，如果我说，如果他们的英雄之一在节目上，我说，哦，林-曼努埃尔·米兰达（Lin-Manuel Miranda）在节目上，或者某某在节目上，不管怎样，不，不，是的，不管怎样。然后他们会看那么一点点。他们会真正关注另一个人在说话。他们对我看我的节目毫无兴趣。我觉得这很有帮助。
I'm in the same boat. My kids hate me when we're going to get to that, Jason, don't worry. Every episode we talk about how much his Bateman's kids hate him, but Sean has never seen arrested development, which is great because two of his, you know, I didn't know that, or maybe I didn't know that. And I just poured cement over it. It's too hurtful to really think about that. I know.
我也一样。我的孩子们讨厌我，我们稍后会谈到这一点，杰森，别担心。每一集我们都谈论贝特曼的孩子们有多讨厌他，但肖恩从来没看过《发展受阻》（Arrested Development），这很好，因为他的两个，你知道，我不知道，或者也许我不知道。我就在上面浇了水泥。想到这一点太伤人了。我知道。
I'm, you know what, you guys, you assholes, I'm going to, I'm going to watch it. I'm going to watch it. No, I'm going to start watching tonight. Sean, it doesn't hold up. It doesn't hold up. You know what it did? It was, it was a moment in comedy. I saw every episode of the Hogan family, every episode of Ozark.
我，你知道吗，你们这些混蛋，我要，我要看它。我要看它。不，我今晚就开始看。肖恩，它经不起推敲。它经不起推敲。你知道它是什么吗？它是喜剧中的一个瞬间。我看过每一集《霍根一家》（The Hogan Family），每一集《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）。
That holds up. Yeah. Now, listen, I'll tell you a funny story, Ashley. I went to... Never say it's a funny story in the front. Just say I'll tell you a story and you'll be the judge. Oh, no, no, no. I meant funny, like kind of weird.
那个经得起推敲。是的。现在，听着，我给你讲个有趣的故事，阿什利。我去了……永远不要在前面说这是一个有趣的故事。就说我会告诉你一个故事，由你来评判。哦，不，不，不。我是说有趣，就像有点奇怪。
This is kind of funny. It's like, like when milk goes funny or like your uncle, like, look out for Uncle Mike. Uncle Mike went funny, but I, I was in, I went to a friend's house, friend of a friend, and they were renting Johnny Halliday. Do you know who that is? The French singer. Yes. Yes.
这有点好笑。就像牛奶变质了，或者像你叔叔，就像，小心迈克叔叔。迈克叔叔变质了，但我，我在，我去了朋友家，朋友的朋友，他们正在租约翰尼·哈里戴（Johnny Halliday）的房子。你知道那是谁吗？法国歌手。是的。是的。
The French Elvis. He passed away a couple of years ago, but he was huge in France, like massive and he sold out. So we went, some new friend of a friend, we were on vacation, they were renting his house down in the Caribbean and he, we go in and he's got one of these like home theater things and he's got like, what's that thing where it's, it's like a digital DVR almost. Like you just got like movies and stuff. They used to load it up.
法国的猫王。他几年前去世了，但在法国他非常出名，就像巨大的那种，而且门票售罄。所以我们去了，一些朋友的新朋友，我们在度假，他们正在加勒比海租他的房子，他，我们进去，他有那种家庭影院之类的东西，他有那种，那叫什么，就像数字硬盘录像机（DVR）之类的。就像你只是有电影之类的。他们过去常把它装满。
Restaurant? Sort of. But they used to, they used to load it up a kaleidoscope or kaleidoscope or something like that. And so you, so you could have 5,000 movies loaded into it or whatever. He had like 25 things available for viewing and they were all concert footage of his, of his own concerts. Oh no.
餐厅？算是吧。但他们过去常，他们过去常把它装满万花筒（kaleidoscope）之类的东西。所以你，所以你可以把5000部电影装进去或者什么的。他只有大约25个东西可供观看，而且全是他自己演唱会的录像。哦，不。
No way. So he had this, he had this home theater with theater seating really nice, like especially in a place in the Caribbean. And then it was all like his concert, like Johnny Halliday returns at the, you know, you know, the stadium, whatever, DP and like crazy like video of him coming off a helicopter, you know, with a hard cut and then all of a sudden he's on stage cause there's no way he, you know, he needed eight people to help him off the helicopter. Well, Conan, you'd be able to stack your top five episodes or, or, or interviews.
不会吧。所以他有这个家庭影院，有剧院座位，真的很棒，特别是在加勒比海这样的地方。然后全都是像他的演唱会，比如约翰尼·哈里戴在，你知道，你知道，体育场，什么的，DP，还有像他从直升机上下来的疯狂视频，你知道，硬切，然后突然他就出现在舞台上了，因为他不可能，你知道，他需要八个人帮他下直升机。好吧，柯南，你能不能列出你的前五名剧集，或者，或者，或者采访。
You could rattle those off. Of my show? Yeah. Well, the gun to your head right now. No, I couldn't. No, no. Come on. I could not.
你可以脱口而出吗？我的节目？是的。好吧，现在枪指着你的头。不，我做不到。不，不。得了吧。我做不到。
I've been doing my show since September of 1993. Who's counting? I've been, uh, there's, there's something like 4,000 hours, uh, one sticks out. What about, would you, when you interviewed Richard Nixon, I mean, wouldn't that stick out in your head? He wasn't, you know what? I think his stories didn't have a strong finish. The thing about Nixon was, did you feel like he was lying?
我从1993年9月就开始做我的节目了。谁在数呢？我已经，呃，有大约4000个小时，呃，有一个很突出。那你呢，当你采访理查德·尼克松（Richard Nixon）时，我的意思是，那不会在你的脑海中很突出吗？他不是，你知道吗？我觉得他的故事没有强有力的结尾。关于尼克松的事情是，你觉得他在撒谎吗？
No, no, it's what he was lying. It's just that he would tell, I mean, first of all, everyone thought, oh, this is great. Conan's going to get the only late night interview ever with, with Richard Nixon. This is, Nixon died as we all know in 94, so he didn't have long to live. I had him on the show and we, he was pissed because he was second on the show. He was second. Sure. It was, one of the kids in the hall was first and I don't even remember which one.
不，不，是他撒谎的内容。只是他会讲，我的意思是，首先，每个人都想，哦，这太棒了。柯南将获得有史以来唯一一次深夜采访理查德·尼克松的机会。这是，尼克松正如我们所知在94年去世，所以他没剩多少时间了。我让他上了节目，我们，他很生气，因为他是节目里的第二个。他是第二个。当然。那是，《Kids in the Hall》里的一个人是第一个，我甚至不记得是哪一个。
Yeah. And then he was, I don't remember which kids in the hall, but he was second and he came out and then he had these stories that he wanted to do and he had this whole bit he wanted to do about, I left a sandwich last time I was here. And it didn't pay off and the audience, what? He did. You are, you are the bit Olympics. I mean, he gave us three minutes of podcast time on just that little tiny hook I threw
是的。然后他是，我不记得是《Kids in the Hall》里的哪一个，但他排在第二个，他出来后，他有一些他想讲的故事，他有一个他想做的完整段子，关于“我上次来的时候落了一个三明治”。而且没有效果，观众，什么？他做了。你是，你是段子奥林匹克。我的意思是，他给了我们三分钟的播客时间，就为了我扔给他的那个小小的钩子。
him. I know. The way he did that. Let me ask you this. You've done four, whatever you said, 4,000 hours. Is that right? Yeah. It feels like five.
我知道。他那样做的方式。让我问你这个。你已经做了四千，不管你说什么，4000个小时。是这样吗？是的。感觉像五千。
Guess what? Six of them. Oh God. I was about to slam myself and he slammed me. You know what? That's the tough thing about being around our net. He'll kill you before you can kill yourself. Who's the better skier, you or Colbert?
猜猜怎么着？六千。哦，天哪。我正要抨击自己，结果他抨击了我。你知道吗？这就是在阿奈特身边艰难的地方。他会在你自杀前先杀了你。谁滑雪更好，你还是科尔伯特？
Um, well, I'll say right now, he was terrified and he does that kind of pizza thing where he puts his skis in and he went to French fries, pizza, French fries, pizza, French fries. And he was saying pizza, French fries, pizza, French fries, pizza, French fries. He went down the hill and it was going really slow. And at one point he just sat down and we were on a green. We were on a green. Was he shitting himself at the time?
嗯，好吧，我现在就说，他吓坏了，他做了那种披萨动作，就是他把滑雪板放进去，然后他变成了炸薯条，披萨，炸薯条，披萨，炸薯条，披萨。他在说披萨，炸薯条，披萨，炸薯条，披萨，炸薯条。他滑下山坡，速度非常慢。在某个时刻，他直接坐下了，我们在绿道上。我们在绿道上。他当时吓尿了吗？
Did he? Well, I couldn't tell. He said there was shit underneath his bottom where he landed before he lost the valve. So he sat down and then there was shit. And then he said, that's someone else's shit. I just happened to sit here and I said, that's fresh. That is fresh shit. Steam is coming off that shit.
他吗？嗯，我看不出来。他说在他失去控制之前，他着陆的地方下面有屎。所以他坐下了，然后就有屎了。然后他说，那是别人的屎。我只是碰巧坐在这里，我说，那是新鲜的。那是新鲜的屎。那屎上还在冒热气。
Yeah. Pizza, French fries, fudge. And then he said, yeah, he said, get me a stretcher. I need a stretcher. And he wasn't hurt at all. And then he- Line it with plastic. Yes.
是的。披萨，炸薯条，软糖。然后他说，是的，他说，给我弄个担架。我需要担架。他根本没受伤。然后他——用塑料垫上。是的。
And so it took about an hour to get a stretcher there and they had to wipe the shit off of them. And he was yelling at these people. I think they had to defrost it first, right? He was yelling at them. Yes. He was yelling at them and being very rude. And then I had to ski down with him.
所以花了一个小时才弄到担架，他们不得不把他身上的屎擦掉。他在对这些人吼叫。我想他们得先把它解冻，对吧？他在对他们吼叫。是的。他在对他们吼叫，而且非常粗鲁。然后我不得不和他一起滑下去。
And whenever they went above like three miles an hour, this is on a stretcher. He would go too fast, too fast, too fast, too fast. This is so inflammatory. This is- Yeah. Ask Steven. Ask Steven if this is true and he will tell you it's true. Ask him.
每当他们超过每小时三英里时，这是在担架上。他就会喊太快了，太快了，太快了，太快了。这太煽动性了。这是——是的。问斯蒂芬。问斯蒂芬这是否属实，他会告诉你这是真的。问他。
I also love the fact that his family does a focus group after every episode. That's a family that loves you. I think that was back in the day. I don't think they do that anymore. This was back probably earlier when his show was newer and he was excited about it. We needed the feedback. And then we all die inside. We all die.
我也喜欢他的家人在每一集之后都会做一个焦点小组的事实。那是一个爱你的家庭。我想那是过去的事了。我不认为他们现在还那样做了。这大概是在他节目比较新的时候，他对此很兴奋。我们需要反馈。然后我们内心都死了。我们都死了。
Clearly. So wait, I want to get back to the mic. My question, you've done over 4,000 hours of television. Here's one of the dumbest questions. Do you still like doing it? No. Okay, great. So my next-
显然。所以等等，我想回到麦克风。我的问题，你已经做了超过4000个小时的电视节目。这是一个最愚蠢的问题。你还喜欢做吗？不。好吧，太棒了。所以我的下一个——
Good night, everybody. I'm so jealous. It is the one thing, one of the things I would love to do. I would love- You'd be very good at it. I don't know about that. I know it's very, very difficult, but it is one thing I always covet it. No, you're doing it now.
晚安，各位。我太嫉妒了。这是唯一一件事，我最想做的事情之一。我想要——你会做得非常好。我不知道。我知道这非常、非常困难，但这是我一直垂涎的一件事。不，你现在就在做。
No, no. I think you- I'm being honest. I think you would be very good at it. I think Sean would be very good at it. Will would do an attitude all the time and he'd be hard to like, you know. People wouldn't- People wouldn't-
不，不。我觉得你——我是认真的。我觉得你会做得非常好。我觉得肖恩会做得非常好。威尔会一直摆架子，他会很难让人喜欢，你知道。人们不会——人们不会——
It would all be like, oh, hello, it's so good to see the audience. Because he'd book people like crazy because they would look so good next to him. But you know what I say? I'll take that. Conan, I'll take that because you are an expert on hard to like, so I am going to take that. You know what? Okay. You know what?
那会像是，哦，你好，见到观众真是太好了。因为他会疯狂地预订嘉宾，因为他们在他身边看起来会很好。但你知道我怎么说吗？我接受。柯南，我接受，因为你是“难以相处”方面的专家，所以我接受。你知道吗？好吧。你知道吗？
Even for you, that was a sloppy swing. That was- And you're a surgeon. You're a surgeon, but you just threw the scalpel across the room. No, you know what? These days, I'm just trying to get on base, man. I'm just- You don't even know whatever it is.
即使对你来说，那也是一次草率的挥杆。那是——你是个外科医生。你是个外科医生，但你刚才把手术刀扔过了房间。不，你知道吗？这些天，我只是想上垒，伙计。我只是——你甚至不知道那是什么。
So, the- No, I really do- I do like it. I enjoy- I mean, this is fun. I mean, getting to talk to you guys. And it's the same thing when you have a show. I've interviewed you all on the program and people think, oh, it must be kind of-
所以，那个——不，我真的——我确实喜欢它。我享受——我的意思是，这很有趣。我的意思是，能和你们聊天。当你有一个节目时也是一样。我在节目上采访过你们所有人，人们会想，哦，那一定有点——
It's a job. And I think it is not a job. It is not a job to talk to really funny people who I would happily have dinner with and we would laugh our asses off. That's a joy. The job part comes in when you have to talk to some people who shouldn't be out there. There are people who are booked by publicists because- I think he means Andy.
这是一份工作。我觉得它不是一份工作。和真正有趣的人聊天，我会很乐意和他们共进晚餐，我们会笑得前仰后合，这根本不是工作。那是一种乐趣。工作的部分在于你必须和一些不该出现在那里的人交谈。有些人是被公关人员预订的，因为——我想他指的是安迪。
Yeah, I think he means Andy. Andy Richter is- I don't get it. He's a fool's fool. Well, and look, trust me, I love Andy because I've been taught that that's the thing to say, but- No, I know what you mean about- It's a chore.
是的，我想他指的是安迪。安迪·里希特（Andy Richter）是——我不明白。他是傻瓜中的傻瓜。好吧，看，相信我，我爱安迪，因为我被教导那是该说的话，但——不，我知道你关于——那是一件苦差事的意思。
It's a job to get through some of those episodes. That's why I asked if you still enjoy it because does that not outweighs the fun guess that make it not a job? But you know, it's great is enough time has gone by and I'm in a nice place, you know, knock wood in my career where I've been around long enough where I don't- If there's someone who I think is going to be really unpleasant to talk to, I just say, let's just not do that person. Good.
完成其中一些剧集是一项工作。这就是为什么我问你是否仍然享受它，因为那难道不会超过那些让它不再是工作的有趣嘉宾吗？但你知道，很棒的是时间已经过去足够久了，我处于一个不错的位置，你知道，敲敲木头，在我的职业生涯中，我已经待得够久了，我不——如果有人我觉得和他们交谈会非常不愉快，我就说，我们还是别找那个人了。好。
When I couldn't have done that in 93, 94, 95, 96. Now I can say, yeah, we just did Sean Hayes like a year ago. Yeah. That's pretty recent. Let's do one is too much. Well, you know, that was the staff talking, not me. That was the consensus. Right.
我在93、94、95、96年的时候可做不到。现在我可以说了，是的，我们一年前刚做了肖恩·海耶斯。是的。那很近。做一个就太多了。嗯，你知道，那是工作人员在说话，不是我。那是共识。对。
Of course. And you don't need the- You don't want your audience- Of course, it comes on late at night, but you don't want them going to bed during the show. You know what I mean? So if you have a Hayes on, that's the risk that you run. Yeah, much better for like a RIPAA or-
当然。而且你不需要——你不想让你的观众——当然，它是在深夜播出的，但你不想让他们在节目期间睡觉。你知道我的意思吗？所以如果你有一个海耶斯在上面，那就是你冒的风险。是的，更适合像《Live with Kelly and Ryan》或者——
Oh, he'd be a great RIPAA. He'd be such a great RIPAA. He'd be such a great RIPAA. Behar. Thanks, you guys. Thanks. Of course. You have a very, you have a powerful, powerful RIPAA energy.
哦，他会是一个很棒的《Live with Kelly and Ryan》嘉宾。他会是一个很棒的《Live with Kelly and Ryan》嘉宾。他会是一个很棒的《Live with Kelly and Ryan》嘉宾。贝哈尔（Behar）。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢。当然。你有一种非常、非常强大的《Live with Kelly and Ryan》能量。
Thanks. Is that the first name or the last name? We're not sure. She's not even sure. No one's sure. They've looked at her birth certificate many times and it seems to just, there's multiple copies. Wait a second.
谢谢。那是名字还是姓氏？我们不确定。她自己都不确定。没人确定。他们看过她的出生证明很多次了，看起来只是，有很多副本。等等。
So there were kind of- Wait a minute. You don't interview people. You don't go wait a second. You don't? Oh, wait. Hang on. Can I ask you a question?
所以有某种——等一下。你不采访人。你不会说“等一下”。你不会吗？哦，等等。等等。我可以问你一个问题吗？
Do it like that, Will. Yeah, yeah. Like that. Jason's got the idea. Go ahead. I don't remember seeing your degree from fucking journalism school, man. So listen. How about that?
像那样做，威尔。是的，是的。像那样。杰森明白了。继续。我不记得看到过你从该死的记者学校拿到的学位，伙计。所以听着。那个怎么样？
How about, look, Conan. Do you- Deal with this. What are you- your show had so many- we talked a little bit about when I came and did your podcast and we talked about all the different kind of phases that you went through a little bit on your show. You started out, you were new at doing it and then you guys kind of created this comedy sort of sketch factory over there really in a lot of ways and you were doing so many bits
那个怎么样，看，柯南。你——处理这个。你是——你的节目有这么多——我们谈到了一点关于我来做你的播客时，我们谈到了你在节目中经历的所有不同阶段。你刚开始的时候，你是新手，然后你们在那边创造了这个喜剧小品工厂，真的在很多方面，而且你们一直在做这么多段子
all the time and it really was a place for guys. We talked about this that guys like me, like I tuned in because I loved watching you guys do that bits and it was you and Stack and you and Brian McCann and John Glazer and all those guys and that was- so like there's been like- it feels like there's been like so many different kind of phases to you being a host of a show. I don't even- Right. Calling you a host is weird.
一直都在做，那真的是一个属于家伙们的地方。我们谈过这个，像我这样的家伙，我收看是因为我喜欢看你们做那些段子，那是你和斯塔克（Stack），你和布莱恩·麦肯（Brian McCann），约翰·格雷泽（John Glazer）还有所有那些家伙，那是——所以就像有——感觉就像你作为节目主持人经历了很多不同的阶段。我甚至——对。称你为主持人很奇怪。
I remember listening to you talk- I forget who you were talking about, talking to on your podcast, talking about your dad and about how you describe what it is that you do. It's hard to describe because there have been- you're a host but you're also- you're also- you kind of do bit- you're in the bits yourself, like you're doing all this stuff. So- Yeah, I never- it's funny. I never wanted to be a host and I never- when people say, oh, you're a talk show host, oh, that always sounded lame to me and it was not something I wanted to do.
我记得听你谈论——我忘了你在和谁谈论，在你的播客上，谈论你的父亲，以及你如何描述你所做的事情。这很难描述，因为有——你是一个主持人，但你也是——你也是——你有点做段子——你自己就在段子里，就像你在做所有这些事情。所以——是的，我从来——很有趣。我从来不想成为一个主持人，我从来——当人们说，哦，你是一个脱口秀主持人，哦，那听起来总是很蹩脚，那不是我想做的事情。
I didn't just want to be a friendly presence. I always wanted us to be coming up with aggressively weird multi-dimensional stuff and I thought, you know, Robert Smigel and I used to talk even before the show went on the air. We had a very specific idea of what the show could be and we thought it's sort of SCTV and Pee Wee's Playhouse and it's Post Letterman because Letterman is irony and detachment. This is going to be very silly and have like children's show elements but also be kind of avant-garde and just ruthlessly like pack as much comedy as we can into each hour and then go do it again.
我不想只是成为一个友好的存在。我一直希望我们能想出极具侵略性的怪异的多维事物，我想，你知道，罗伯特·斯密格尔（Robert Smigel）和我在节目播出前就经常谈论。我们对节目可以是什么有一个非常具体的想法，我们认为它是《SCTV》和《皮威的游乐场》（Pee Wee's Playhouse），它是后大卫·莱特曼（Letterman）时代的，因为莱特曼是讽刺和超脱。这将是非常愚蠢的，有像儿童节目一样的元素，但也有一种前卫的感觉，并且无情地像在每一小时里塞进尽可能多的喜剧，然后再次去做。
So the idea that being just a guy who's like, well, welcome to the show, I'm a pleasant fellow and I'm- I go down easy and that was our show. That was never what I wanted to do. And so- And you came off, you'd written on SNL and then you'd- and then you'd gone and written on The Simpsons. It went that way, didn't it? Yeah.
所以，仅仅做一个像“好吧，欢迎来到节目，我是一个讨人喜欢的家伙，我——我很容易相处”的人的想法，那是我们的节目。那从来不是我想做的。所以——而且你出来时，你写过《周六夜现场》（SNL），然后你——然后你去写了《辛普森一家》（The Simpsons）。是那样走的，不是吗？是的。
And then SNL and then Simpsons, yeah. And then so you did Simpsons, which again, like that was a very sort of, you know, obviously the time that you were there was really at the infancy of it, the surreal era of The Simpsons and kind of made The Simpsons what they are today. And you brought that kind of energy or that kind of vibe to late night in a way. Like you made it kind of surreal. Well, I'm very, I mean, you know, it's hard not to be boring when talking about your own work, but I'll, and I probably already have been, but it just like sound out live.
然后是《周六夜现场》，然后是《辛普森一家》，是的。然后你做了《辛普森一家》，这再次，就像那是一个非常，你知道，显然你待在那里的时间确实是在它的初期，超现实时代的《辛普森一家》，并且某种程度上造就了今天的《辛普森一家》。你把那种能量或那种氛围带到了深夜节目中。就像你让它变得有点超现实。嗯，我非常，我的意思是，你知道，谈论你自己的工作时很难不无聊，但我会，而且我可能已经很无聊了，但这只是听起来很现场。
My sketches were always very cartoony and silly. And then I went to an actual cartoon, The Simpsons, and really felt comfortable there. And then I think when I got my late night show, there was a lot of Warner Brothers cartoon influence that I wanted to bring into late night. And- Yeah, because you know, when they promote late night talk shows, not just late night, any talk shows, it's almost like the thing that leads the promotion is the guest. And-
我的小品总是非常卡通和愚蠢。然后我去了真正的卡通片，《辛普森一家》，在那里真的感到很舒服。然后我想当我得到我的深夜节目时，有很多华纳兄弟卡通的影响，我想带进深夜节目。而且——是的，因为你知道，当他们推广深夜脱口秀时，不仅仅是深夜，任何脱口秀，几乎就像推广的重点是嘉宾。而且——
And then they would promote your show. I would always tune in because of you, because of all, that was more like a show. It was a sketch show. It was a variety show. You and Mr. T writing, you know, going out to pick apples or whatever. Apple pick. And there was a thing we did where like, to me, it was what we did with the guest. So, you know, years and years ago, we had Tom Selleck on.
然后他们会推广你的节目。我总是因为你而收看，因为所有，那更像是一个节目。那是一个小品节目。那是一个综艺节目。你和T先生（Mr. T）写，你知道，出去摘苹果什么的。苹果采摘。我们做过一件事，对我来说，就是我们和嘉宾做的事情。所以，你知道，很多年前，我们请了汤姆·塞立克（Tom Selleck）。
And, you know, Tom Selleck, that's a still a good, that's still a great booking. But like then it was just like, oh my God, it's Tom Selleck. And we talked him into, he had just shaved his mustache, we had shaved it like a year before and it was sort of a thing like- For Quigley Down Under? Is that why? I don't know what it was. I swear to God, I don't know what it was for.
而且，你知道汤姆·塞立克，那仍然是一个很好的，那仍然是一个很棒的预订。但那时就像，哦，天哪，是汤姆·塞立克。我们说服他，他刚刮了胡子，我们一年前刮过，这有点像——为了《奎格利下澳洲》（Quigley Down Under）？是因为那个吗？我不知道是为了什么。我发誓，我不知道是为了什么。
It wasn't for a movie, I don't think, but he had, and no reason to throw Quigley Down Under. I think he had lost a bet. Are you impressed with Quigley Down Under? Yeah, that was a great pull. Deep cut. So, there was a bet before you guys did this, I bet I can work in Quigley Down Under and you did it.
我不认为是为了电影，但他有，而且没有理由提到《奎格利下澳洲》。我想他打赌输了。你对《奎格利下澳洲》印象深刻吗？是的，那是一个很棒的拉动。深层剪辑。所以，在你们做这个之前有一个赌注，我打赌我可以把《奎格利下澳洲》加进去，而你做到了。
Nice going. Nicely done. Yeah. Nicely done. Yeah, and he was just about to say, I think the way to save race relations in America and you went, is Quigley Down Under? And he went, what? And you went, I won the bet, Bateman, I won the bet.
干得好。做得漂亮。是的。做得漂亮。是的，他正要说，我认为拯救美国种族关系的办法是，而你去了，是《奎格利下澳洲》吗？他去了，什么？你去了，我赢了赌注，贝特曼，我赢了赌注。
And then Obama lost his train of thought and you guys said, we're out of time, remember that? Well, the worst part was that Obama lost his train of thought. Well, because of your idiocy, no discredit to the great man himself, a good friend of mine by the way. Of course. He's here. He's downstairs, he's making a protein shake.
然后奥巴马失去了思路，你们说，我们没时间了，记得吗？嗯，最糟糕的部分是奥巴马失去了思路。嗯，因为你的白痴行为，不是对这位伟人本人的不敬，顺便说一句，他是我的好朋友。当然。他在这里。他在楼下，他在做蛋白奶昔。
So anyway, we did this whole thing like, I didn't want to talk to Tom Selleck about his career. We said a whole thing where we said, we found your mustache and your mustache misses you and we reunited him. I remember that. I remember that. And then he came back a second time and he still didn't have the mustache and we said, we reunited you last time and he was like, yeah, yeah, I remember that.
所以无论如何，我们做了整个事情，就像，我不想和汤姆·塞立克谈论他的职业生涯。我们说了一整套东西，我们说，我们找到了你的胡子，你的胡子想你了，我们让他重聚了。我记得那个。我记得那个。然后他第二次回来，他仍然没有胡子，我们说，我们上次让你重聚了，他就像，是的，是的，我记得那个。
And then we said, well, we got bad news for you, the mustache is terminally ill. And we cut to a little miniature hospital bed and the mustache was dying. And we said, if you have anything as you want to say to the mustache, and there was a nurse there and a doctor. And then of course, Tom Selleck went over to say goodbye to the mustache. And then when he looked both ways and he picked up, he did it really well. He's very funny. Picked up a pillow.
然后我们说，好吧，我们有个坏消息要告诉你，胡子病危了。我们切到一个小小的微型医院病床，胡子快死了。我们说，如果你有什么想对胡子说的，那里有一个护士和一个医生。然后当然，汤姆·塞立克走过去告别胡子。然后当他两边看了看，他拿起了，他做得非常好。他非常有趣。拿起了一个枕头。
What's happening, how is this a celebrity interview, but now was that cleared with it? Was that part of like the pre-interview and all that stuff, or did you just kind of spring that on him? You know what I'm going to say? I'm going to say we probably told him about it when he got there and he's a good sport and he went along with it. There have been many, we had a, there have been many times where it's gone very badly. Ringo Starr was on the show once and the writers had a funny idea.
发生了什么，这怎么会是名人采访，但那是事先清理过的吗？那是预采访之类的一部分，还是你只是把它强加给他了？你知道我要说什么吗？我会说我们可能在他到的时候告诉了他，他是个好运动，他顺从了。有很多，我们有一个，有很多次情况变得非常糟糕。林戈·斯塔尔（Ringo Starr）曾经上过节目，编剧们有一个有趣的想法。
Which was, I say, Ringo, do you want to sit in with the, hey, Ringo, why don't you sit in with the band? No, no, I possibly could. No, come on, Ringo, do it. Oh, oh, right. And he walks over there and picks up a saxophone and just starts to wail, which we thought, that's a funny idea. And the band plays out and that would be like a funny clip.
那就是，我说，林戈，你想和乐队一起坐坐吗，嘿，林戈，你为什么不和乐队一起坐坐？不，不，我可能可以。不，得了吧，林戈，做吧。哦，哦，对。他走过去拿起萨克斯风，就开始吹奏，我们想，那是个有趣的想法。乐队演奏结束，那会像是一个有趣的片段。
And the writers came to me and I said, you know what, they said it's a beetle, you got to go pitch it to him. And I said, I'll pitch it to him. And I, the writers were like, you know, Conan's going to stand up for us and he's going to really pitch it and sell it. And I went into Ringo's dressing room and I said, oh, Ringo, we have an idea for a bit. And he said, let's hear it.
编剧们来找我，我说，你知道吗，他们说那是披头士，你得去向他推销。我说，我会去推销。我，编剧们就像，你知道，柯南会为我们挺身而出，他会真正推销并卖掉它。我走进林戈的更衣室，我说，哦，林戈，我们有一个段子的想法。他说，让我们听听。
And I said, so anyway, the idea is I say, hey, Ringo's going to sit in with the band and you cross over, but instead you pick up a saxophone. And without missing a bit, Ringo went, I won't do it. And I, without missing a beat said, and I don't blame you, he went, I won't do it. And I said, and I don't blame you. It's not worthy of you. And it's not a good idea. And the writers like, fuck you, man.
我说，所以无论如何，想法是我说，嘿，林戈要和乐队一起坐坐，你走过去，但你拿起的是萨克斯风。林戈没有错过任何一个节拍，说，我不会做的。我，没有错过任何一个节拍说，我不怪你，他去了，我不会做的。我说，我不怪你。它配不上你。这不是个好主意。编剧们就像，去你的，伙计。
And I'm like, hey, it's not Ringo quality. So forget it. And so, I love selling them out. Have you ever had a guest on the show that went through the publicist said, this is particularly off limits. Do not touch this area. Do not ask this question. And you said, screw it.
我就像，嘿，这不是林戈的质量。所以算了吧。所以，我喜欢出卖他们。你有没有遇到过嘉宾，通过公关人员说，这绝对是禁区。不要碰这个领域。不要问这个问题。而你说，去他的。
And you went ahead with it anyway as a result of them not being a great guest or basically they kind of brought it on themselves. No, I am, you know what? I would not do that. Come on. What if there were just a terrible, you can, you can tell they're not trying at all. They're giving yes, no answers. They're not hitting the ball back and you just, you just unload the noise on them.
你还是继续做了，结果他们不是一个好的嘉宾，或者基本上他们有点自找的。不，我，你知道吗？我不会那样做。得了吧。如果他们只是一个糟糕的，你可以，你可以看出他们根本没在尝试。他们给出是、否的回答。他们没有把球打回来，你就，你就把噪音卸给他们。
You know what? I'm, I'm very, I'm not, I'm going to be really serious about this. It's not even a moral choice. It's not, some people are really funny, you know, when they, like I think David Letterman, one of his, and it's, I think one part of his brilliance is he can be this incredibly, he can be this wit that eviscerates people and, and, and, and really brilliantly and, and really brilliant. And people that deserve it, I don't have, I'm not good at that.
你知道吗？我，我非常，我将非常认真地对待这一点。这甚至不是一个道德选择。这不是，有些人真的很有趣，你知道，当他们，就像我觉得大卫·莱特曼，他的其中一个，我认为这是他才华的一部分，他可以成为这种令人难以置信的，他可以成为这种能把人剖开的机智，而且，而且，而且真的非常出色，而且真的非常出色。那些值得的人，我不擅长那个。
I can actually do it with my friends when I'm kidding and I know that their feelings won't really be hurt. I can be incredibly, I can really unload on them and I think be artfully mean or artfully sarcastic when they know the deal with me and it's safe. There's a safe word. That doesn't transfer on TV or with people that you don't know and I, whenever I've done, this is true. Whenever I do bits where I commit a hundred percent and I'm a complete asshole, I can
我实际上可以在和朋友开玩笑时做到这一点，我知道他们的感情不会真的受到伤害。我可以非常，我可以真正地卸下他们，我认为在他们知道我和我的交易并且安全时，可以艺术地刻薄或艺术地讽刺。有一个安全词。这在电视上或和你不知道的人在一起时不会转移，而且我，每当我做过，这是真的。每当我做我百分之百投入并且我是一个彻头彻尾的混蛋的段子时，我可以
feel the crowd. They don't love it. They don't love it because they do think they are seeing mostly me, even though I'm also participating in bits. They are seeing mostly me and you have such a great, you know, vulnerable, baked in vulnerability and like non-assholiness that you could probably get away with being a whole lot more. What are you watching? I'd love to see you try to be a super duper asshole to want to, you should just pick one
感觉到人群。他们不喜欢它。他们不喜欢它，因为他们确实认为他们看到的主要是真实的我，即使我也在参与段子。他们看到的主要是真实的我，而你有这样一个伟大的，你知道，脆弱的，内置的脆弱性，以及像非混蛋性，你可能可以逃脱做更多的事情。你在看什么？我很想看你尝试做一个超级无敌的混蛋，你应该只选一个
and just give us a text, just give us a little heads up, tune in tonight, I'm going to fire bullets. You know what I do? No, I could find, there have been one, there have been sketches where I'm a complete over the top creep and it has worked, but I think it took a long time. People had to get to know the real me to then, I mean, early in the show, I think we had the gymnast Mary Lou Retin on, this is how long the show has been on. I had a crazy crush on her.
然后给我们发个短信，给我们一点提示，今晚收看，我要开火了。你知道我做什么吗？不，我可以找到，有一些小品是我是一个彻头彻尾的令人毛骨悚然的人，它奏效了，但我认为这花了很多时间。人们必须了解真实的我，然后，我的意思是，在节目早期，我想我们请了体操运动员玛丽·卢·雷顿（Mary Lou Retton），这就是节目播出了多久。我疯狂地迷恋她。
We had Mary Lou Retin on and we did a bit where I just completely unload on her and I committed a hundred and ten percent. America's sweetheart? You kind of think better than that. Yes, and we thought it would be really funny and I completely, well, that was the whole idea is that she just said something really innocent. It was one of those things we taped in a commercial break and then we saved it and then, you know, a week later Andy went, yeah, we're getting some, you know, I'll do Andy, sorry.
我们请了玛丽·卢·雷顿，我们做了一个段子，我完全卸下了她，我投入了一百一十个百分点。美国的甜心？你有点认为比那更好。是的，我们认为这会非常有趣，我完全，好吧，这就是整个想法，她只是说了些非常无辜的话。这是我们在商业广告中录制的那些事情之一，然后我们保存了它，然后，你知道，一周后安迪去了，是的，我们得到了一些，你知道，我会做安迪，抱歉。
We're getting some blowback and I went, what do you mean, you were kind of rough on Mary Lou Retin. No, I wasn't. Yeah, you are. Take a look at the clip and I completely unload on her and I had people on the street saying, you know what, I am never watching you again. Yeah. Why do you hate America?
我们得到了一些反弹，我说，什么意思，你对玛丽·卢·雷顿有点粗鲁。不，我没有。是的，你是。看看那个片段，我完全卸下了她，我在街上有人说，你知道吗，我再也不会看你了。是的。你为什么恨美国？
Why did you treat it her? And I'm like, it's clearly a bit, it's, you know, yeah. When you did Arrested, I think I've told you this before, one of my favorite laughs on Arrested ever was when you were on it and Andy is standing next to you, getting your makeup done backstage or something like that. I forget why Michael Bluth is there to talk to you or whatever. Anyway, you're getting your makeup done and Andy walks by and he stops and he's looking at you and you finish talking to me and you say to him, you say, hey, Andy, by the way,
你为什么要那样对待她？我就像，这显然是一个段子，它，你知道，是的。当你做《发展受阻》时，我想我之前告诉过你，我在《发展受阻》中最喜欢的笑声之一是当你出现在上面时，安迪站在你旁边，在后台化妆什么的。我忘了迈克尔·布鲁斯（Michael Bluth）为什么在那里和你说话什么的。无论如何，你在化妆，安迪走过，他停下来，他在看着你，你结束和我说话，你对他说，你说，嘿，安迪，顺便说一句，
next time I stopped talking, that's not your cue to talk. It was the biggest, it was so dry, it was without any cover whatsoever, it was the biggest asshole thing. Yeah. It's fun. It's fun. It is fun to be incredibly, just with anyone, it's really fun to turn it, as you guys know. We had a, one of our writers is this brilliant, brilliant writer and really brilliant comic
下次我停止说话时，那不是你说话的提示。它太干了，它没有任何掩饰，它是最大的混蛋行为。是的。这很有趣。这很有趣。做一个彻头彻尾的混蛋很有趣，只是和任何人在一起，正如你们所知，把它转过来真的很有趣。我们有一个，我们的编剧之一是这位才华横溢、才华横溢的编剧，而且非常出色的漫画家
Lori Kilmartin. She's just fantastic and she's one of my favorite people and this is a little heavy, but she lost her mom recently to COVID and she wrote these tweets about it that were funny and powerful at the same time and just sort of perfect and we decided to talk to her on the show and we just did a couple of days ago and I talked to her about it and it was this really powerful segment and she's talking about losing her mom, but she's also, you know, she's being funny, but she's also, she's walking this razor's edge and then finally it got a little emotional and she said, but I really missed my mom and I said, well,
洛里·基尔马丁（Lori Kilmartin）。她简直太棒了，她是我最喜欢的人之一，这有点沉重，但她最近因为新冠失去了她的妈妈，她写了这些关于它的推文，既有趣又强大，而且简直完美，我们决定在节目中和她谈谈，我们就在几天前做了，我和她谈了这件事，这是一个非常强大的片段，她在谈论失去她的妈妈，但她也，你知道，她在变得有趣，但她也，她在走这条剃刀边缘，然后最后它变得有点情绪化，她说，但我真的很想念我的妈妈，我说，好吧，
Lori, I'm just a huge fan and you're fired, you know, and I just, and it was, it was, it was such the wrong thing to do at the wrong moment that firing her at that moment was just so much fun. She laughed. Yeah. No, very upset. Come on. Then I had to fire her.
Lori，我只是你的超级粉丝，你被解雇了，你知道的，我只是，而且这，这，这在那个时刻做这件事太不对了，以至于在那一刻解雇她真的太有趣了。她笑了。是啊。不，非常难过。拜托。然后我不得不解雇她。
And because of what he did, here's the thing, he always follows through with his bits, so he actually fired her. I did let her go because she didn't laugh immediately and that I won't have. Right. How do you like doing the show from home? Would you do it that way forever and for always if you could? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I think, I think we can all agree here, gentlemen, that one must, I, maybe you guys won't agree.
因为他所做的事，重点是，他总是会把他的段子演到底，所以他真的解雇了她。我确实让她走了，因为她没有立刻笑出来，而我是不会容忍那种事的。没错。你喜欢在家做节目吗？如果可以的话，你会永远一直那样做吗？不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，我想，我想我们大家都能同意，各位，一个人必须，我，也许你们不会同意。
I believe that the way a salmon swims upstream to spawn in the morning, I have to get it in a car. Beautiful. Thank you. Keep going. I have to get in a car, just like a salmon does, and drive an electric car. Wait, you're not. Yeah.
我相信就像鲑鱼早上逆流而上去产卵一样，我必须得坐进车里。太美了。谢谢。继续。我必须坐进车里，就像鲑鱼一样，然后开一辆电动车。等等，你不是。是啊。
Did I go too far? No. The salmon has an electric car and lives on the west side of LA. Wait, wait, wait. Let's stop. Just so I can understand the rules. So there's a salmon that lives on the west side of LA. Yeah.
我做得太过分了吗？没有。那条鲑鱼有一辆电动车，住在洛杉矶西区。等等，等等，等等。停一下。为了让我理解规则。所以有一条住在洛杉矶西区的鲑鱼。是啊。
Yes. And it has an electric car. And it's beloved. It's beloved and very hard to book on a podcast and it's really the exception when it does someone else's podcast because it has its own podcast. Why would it do someone else's? Anyway, the point is the salmon is, and the salmon's had an eye job recently and it hasn't gone well.
是的。而且它有一辆电动车。而且它很受欢迎。它很受欢迎，而且很难约到它上播客，它上别人的播客真的是例外，因为它有自己的播客。它为什么要上别人的？总之，重点是那条鲑鱼，而且那条鲑鱼最近做了眼部手术，效果不太好。
Wow. The salmon's busy. Yeah. The salmon's name is Cronin. And anyway, I believe you've got to get up in the morning, like the salmon in the car with the eye job, and you have to go to work. Does the salmon look like it's combed its hair with a pork chop too, or what is the deal?
哇。那条鲑鱼真忙。是啊。那条鲑鱼的名字叫克罗宁。总之，我相信你早上必须起床，就像那条开着有眼部手术的车里的鲑鱼一样，你必须去工作。那条鲑鱼看起来是不是也像用猪排梳过头一样，还是怎么回事？
Now, Will, this is our guest. Pork chop. What is, what is? You know, that's not, what does that mean? I will say there's not as much body in the pork chop with your home version of Cronin as there is in the stage where you could tell me. Ask any engineer. Yeah.
好了，威尔，这是我们的嘉宾。猪排。什么是，什么是？你知道，那不是，那是什么意思？我要说的是，你家里那个版本的克罗宁，其猪排发型没有舞台上那么有质感，你可以告诉我。问问任何工程师就知道了。是啊。
I have not had a haircut in quite a while. What happens when the upper shelf was pure weight, it's pure weight, the shelf collapsed about three weeks ago and it happened in the night. It happened in the night and three workmen were killed and it happened in the night and it woke everyone up and, and I came running out and people said, what was that? And I suddenly had bangs and, you came running out in your night shirt in your long, I did. Yeah. I looked like Mo Howard circa 1968 in a night shirt and I came running out and I said, what
我好久没剪头发了。当上层架子全是重量时会发生什么，那是纯粹的重量，架子在大约三周前塌了，而且发生在晚上。它发生在晚上，三个工人丧生了，它发生在晚上，把所有人都吵醒了，我跑了出来，人们说，那是什么？我突然有了刘海，而且，你穿着睡衣跑了出来，你那长长的，我确实。是啊。我看起来就像1968年左右穿着睡衣的莫·霍华德，我跑出来说，发生了什么，发生了什么？他们说你的头发。这是自93年以来它第一次掉下来。我不再有那个标志性的柯南式发型了，我现在什么也做不了。我知道我看起来有点像肖恩·卡西迪。它毛茸茸的。它向后吹。我随身带着一个风扇。
happened, what happened? And they went your hair. It fell for the first time since 93. And I no longer had that iconic Conan pump and it, there's nothing I can do right now. I know I'm sort of have like a Sean Cassidy. It's feathery. It blows back. I carry a fan around.
我在女士们中很受欢迎。这是全新的生活。那头发，那张脸，那个身高，还有肩膀等等，我就是这么说的。我是在说肩膀。什么肩膀？不，就像你周末盖房子一样，对吧？我是说，看看你。
I'm very popular with the ladies. It's a whole new life. That hair and that face and that height and the shoulders and everything, that's what I said. I was talking about the shoulders. What's the shoulders? No, it's like you build houses on the weekends, right? I mean, look at you.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。所以威尔刚才说的，你无法隐藏。你喜欢当你身处人群中，人们，你知道，他们走过来，他们，他们有赞美，或者他们有笔记，或者不管他们有什么要给你的。你喜欢和美国对话吗？
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. So what Will was saying at the beginning, you can't hide. How do you, how do you like when you're out amongst your people and people, you know, they come up and they, and they got, they got compliments or they got notes or whatever the hell they've got for you. Do you like talking to America?
你是，你是一个害羞的人吗？哦，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。他们不得不引用伟大的洛恩·迈克尔斯的话，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。我是说，这太荒谬了。他们走近我，说，嘿，见到你真高兴。我开始说话，然后他们就给了我一个明确的信号。好吧，总之，见到你真是太激动了，我说，但你说你是来自佛罗里达。
Are you, are you a shy guy or? Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. And they had to quote the great Lord, Michael's no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I mean, it's ridiculous. They tire, they approached me and say, Hey, I'm really happy to meet you. I start talking and then they give me a clear. Well, anyway, it was a thrill to meet you and I say, but you said that you're from Florida.
是狭长地带还是海岸？他们就像，而且他们实际上正在走开，而我正朝他们走去。他穿了一件T恤，上面写着，请求和我自拍。是啊。有人给名人的友好度打分。拜托。这是一本大概，
Would that be the panhandle or the coast? And they're like, and they're actually walking away and I'm walking towards them and. He's got a T-shirt that says, ask to take a selfie with me. Yeah. Someone rated celebrities on friendliness. Come on. And this is a book that came out like,
不，大概15年前出的书，一些追星族。我想有两个家伙写了一本书。我想我，我不是在吹牛，因为我觉得这比什么都更可悲，但我得到了最高的评价之一，就因为，哦，这家伙会陪你走到车边，还会打扫房间。你妻子对此怎么看？你的孩子们对此怎么看？
no, like 15 years ago, some autograph hounds. I think two guys wrote a book. And I think I, I'm not bragging here cause I think it's more sad than anything else, but I got like one of the highest ratings for just, oh, this guy will walk you to your car and clean the room. How does your wife feel about that? And how do your kids feel about that?
当人们走过来开始和他们的爸爸说话时，他们会觉得奇怪吗？不，他们，他们很酷。我妻子非常好，她经常主动提出帮忙拍照，让照片效果更好。我是说，她，我很幸运，因为我知道，你知道，有些人有配偶会说，哦天哪，为什么总是关于你？
Do they get weirded out when people come up and start talking to their dad? No, they're, they're very cool. My wife is very nice and she will often offer to take the picture to make it better. I mean, she's, I'm very lucky cause I know, you know, some people have a spouse that's like, oh my God, why is it about you?
肖恩。是啊。嗯，是的。你见过斯科蒂，对吧？我是说。哦天哪。我见过斯科蒂吗？一拳打在你的脖子上。
Sean. Yeah. Well, yes. You've met Scotty, right? I mean. Oh my God. Did I meet Scotty? Punch you right in the neck.
但我刚换了他的电池。他又恢复正常工作了。好了，宝贝，阿曼达会帮别人拍很多照片吗？她最喜欢的把戏就是让我帮他们拍，然后她会把相机转过来，给自己拍几张头像，然后还给他们说，拍得不错。
But I just changed his batteries. He's right back up and running. All right, baby, does Amanda take a lot of photos for other people? Her favorite trick is just let me take it and then she'll flip the camera around, she'll take a couple of headshots of herself and hand it back and go, good ones.
梭罗以前在和本·斯蒂勒跑步时也会那样做，他告诉我人们不得不和本·斯蒂勒合影，他会说，好的，我来拍。然后他会把本排除在取景框外，然后他会回来，然后他们继续走。太棒了。太棒了。
Thoreau used to do that with, when he was like running with Ben Cyiller, he told me that people would have to take a photo with Ben Cyiller and he go, yeah, I'll take it. And he'd frame Ben out and then he'd get back and then they keep walking. That's great. That's great.
他们会说，嘿，这事真的在纽约发生在我身上，最老套的陈词滥调。有人，有一个大家庭，他们走过来对我说，你介意拍张照吗？我当时想，当然。然后他们把相机递给了我。是的，猜猜怎么着？一周前在卡平特里亚的海滩上发生在我身上，
And they'd be like, hey, I actually had happened to me in New York, the biggest cliche ever. Somebody, there was a big family and they came up to me and they said, would you mind taking a photo? And I was like, sure. And then they handed me the camera. Yes, guess what? Happened to me a week ago on the beach in Carpentaria,
一群来自亚利桑那州凤凰城的人走过来问，哦天哪，你介意吗？我说，不，他们举起相机，然后让我给他们拍张照。当时我戴着口罩，但口罩上写着，我是柯南·奥布莱恩。所以我受伤了。我也有那个，我也有同样的口罩。
a bunch of people from Phoenix, Arizona walked up and said, oh my God, would you mind? And I went, no, and they held up the camera and then they asked me to take a picture of them. Now I was wearing a mask, but the mask said, I am Conan O'Brien. So I was hurt. I had that too, I had that same mask.
我做了一个口罩，我上周用这支记号笔为Zoom会议做了一个，我在口罩上写了我的名字，我是威尔·奥尼尔。然后我开始担心，因为我们去取外卖，我对女朋友说，我出了车，我下车了一会儿，我正要把它拿起来，我回来后说，我没戴那个写着，
I did a mask, I did it with this Sharpie last week for a meeting on Zoom where I wrote my name, I'm Will O'Neill on the mask. And then I got worried because we went to pick up some takeout and I said to my girlfriend, I went out of the car, I got out of the car for a second, I was about to pick it up and I came back and I go, I'm not wearing the one that says,
不，不，你没问题。我不会让你下车的。我能问个简单的问题吗？我可以，我是描绘口头图画的大师。我知道问题是什么。今天肩膀和手臂。然后微笑作为腿和背部。不，不，不，那又是你在谈论我了。
no, no, you're good. I wouldn't let you out of the car. Can I ask a quick question? I can, I'm a master at painting a verbal picture. I know what the question is. As shoulders and arms today. And then smile as legs and back. No, no, no, that's what we're talking about me again.
好吧。我的问题是，我们四个人中的三个，处于一个自然的环境中，在家里闲逛。威尔，你，很明显，你在伦敦的艾比路录音室，你在一个专业的录音棚里。你这是怎么回事？
Okay. My question is most, the three of us, three of us, of the four of us, are in just a natural environment, hanging out in our homes. Will, you are in, clearly, you are at Abbey Road Studios in London and you are in a professional booth. What's your deal?
你有什么问题？问题是，你不需要进入配音状态，因为你在配音室里。你在做福特卡车的广告吗？GMC，小心点，柯南。哦，抱歉，抱歉。GMC，我们是专业级的。朋友不会让朋友开福特。
What's your problem? The deal is, you don't have to go into VO voice because you're in a VO room. Were you doing a Ford truck ad? GMC, careful Conan. Oh, sorry, sorry. GMC, we are professional grade. Friends don't let friends drive Fords.
听着，重点是。这只是我做我自己。我想问你，因为你是地球上最有趣的人之一。你还在每天为你的节目构思1000个段子吗？还是你现在完全依赖你的编剧，
Listen, here's the thing. This is just me being me. I wanted to ask you because you're one of the funniest people on the face of the earth. Are you still contributing every single day to thinking of 1,000 bits for your show or do you solely rely at this point on your writers
而你偶尔插嘴？你是在家里走来走去不断地想段子吗？你想让我承认自己是一个腐烂的躯壳吗？不，一点也不。再也不在乎了。是啊，你口袋里有小段子本吗？我没有段子本，
and you occasionally chime in? Are you walking around your house thinking of bits constantly? You want me to admit to being a rotted husk. No, not at all. It doesn't give a shit anymore. Yeah, do you have a little bit book in your pocket? I don't have a bit book,
但我确实记得，我很多时候会想到一些事情，然后我就把它们演出来，这就是我做过的一些我最喜欢的、真的很蠢的事情的由来，我想把功劳归给我的编剧们。他们写了大部分的东西，而且他们多年来写了大部分标志性的东西，所以，
but I do remember, I think of things a lot of times and I'll just act them out and that's how some of my favorite things that are really stupid that I've done, I want to give it up to my writers. They write the lion's share of the stuff and they've written the lion's share of the stuff that's iconic over the years and so,
但我口袋里有一个我喜欢的段子，总是叫《谁偷了软糖？》。这只是我当时说，现在我们要做一个叫《谁偷了软糖？》的环节。我实际上是在新冠疫情初期的节目中做的，因为我当时就坐在我现在坐的地方。我最初没有编剧。我根本不知道我要做什么，
but I had a bit in my back pocket that I love which is always called Who Stole the Fudge? And it was just me saying like, now we're going to do a segment called Who Stole the Fudge? And I did this actually during the first early COVID shows because I'm sitting right where I'm sitting now. I have no writers initially. I had no idea what I was going to do
我只是说，哦，我会做这个我想到的段子。所以我真的只是在我身后的小杯子里放了一些融化的巧克力软糖糖霜，我就说，嗯，有一个小段子叫《谁偷了软糖？》。等一下。然后我转过身说，谁偷了软糖？然后我猛地转过来，我的脸上涂满了它。
and I was just saying like, oh, I'll do this bit that I thought of. And so I literally just had some melted chocolate fudge frosting behind me in a little cup and I just went, well, there's a little bit called Who Stole the Fudge? Hold on a second. And then I just turn around and I say Who Stole the Fudge? And I whip around and my face is smeared with it.
我说，哈，软糖？有人拿了软糖？然后我完全做了一个，我不知道，不，我没见过软糖。我希望。然后重点是，我会帮你找。我会帮你。这太——
And I go, huh, fudges? Someone took fudge? And then I just totally do a, I didn't know, no, I've not seen fudge. I hope. And then the thing is like, I'll help you look. I'll help you. And it's so-
你的电视网立刻停止了支票支付。嗯，你知道那个故事有多疯狂吗？这是绝对真实的。贝特曼，我不确定你当时是否在场。肖恩，我很确定你在场。我们三个人多年来一直在一起打牌，安迪经常和我们一起玩。有一次在我威尼斯的旧居，
Your network immediately stopped payment on the check. Well, you know what's so crazy about that story? This is absolutely true. Bateman, I'm not sure if you were there. Sean, I'm pretty sure you were there. The three of us used to play cards together for years and years ago and Andy would often play with us. And one time in my old place in Venice,
记得我在那个地方，布拉德利就在隔壁。嗯，以前就住在布拉德利·库珀隔壁。是啊，你住在谁上面？罗恩·里夫金。是啊。罗恩·里夫金和他妻子在前边，布拉德利·库珀和我在后边。
remember I was in that place and Bradley was right in the thing next door. Well used to live right next to Bradley Cooper. Yeah, who'd you live above? Ron Rivkin. Yeah. Ron Rivkin and his wife from the front, Bradley Cooper and I were in the back.
我们有后屋。嗯，真是个三人组。你们三个家伙一起做过什么吗？你们去过圣莫尼卡码头吗？专业的事情还是什么？你是说事情。斜体字的事情。我们从来没一起做过什么，伙计。
We had the back house. Well, such a threesome. Did the three of you guys ever do stuff together? Did you ever go down to Santa Monica Pier? Professional stuff or stuff? You mean stuff. Stuff in italics. We never did stuff together, man.
你是说那天晚上，就像灯熄灭的时候？哦，继续你的……欢迎来到播客。所以总之，那天晚上我们在打牌，我不开玩笑，非常相似，有人买了，我想皮特·贾尔斯买了一些饼干或软糖之类的东西，安迪，有人说，
You mean that night, like when the lights are out? Oh, continue with your... Welcome to the podcast. So anyway, so one night we're playing cards and I'm not kidding, very similarly, somebody had bought some, I think Pete Giles had bought some cookies or fudge or something and Andy, somebody said,
嘿安迪，当你上去的时候，能把那个，把那个巧克力拿下来吗？同样的，但这真是个该死的经典。我不知道我为什么要说这个。我们会剪掉这一部分。我们只保留你的。不，不，不，不，它是……但安迪下来了，他有软糖，
hey Andy, when you're up there, can you bring that, bring that chocolate down? And the same, but it's a fucking classic. I don't know why I'm telling this. We'll cut this part out. We'll just leave yours in. No, no, no, no, it's... But Andy came down and he had fudge,
他说，我找不到你。你不在，你不在。是啊，安迪做了，安迪做了一件事。我记得他做的第一件事，我们在某个，我想我们在录节目，灯突然熄灭了，这意味着，30号大楼发生了某种电力激增或故障，灯熄灭了，
and he goes, I couldn't find you. You wasn't in, you were not in. Yeah, Andy did, Andy did a thing. I remember one of the first things he did, we were in some, I think we were taping a show and the lights just suddenly went out, which was, I mean, there was some power surge or failure at 30 Rock and the lights went out
安迪毫不犹豫地尖叫道，我的珍珠。我当时就像，这种经典的马克思兄弟，三个臭皮匠，我的珍珠。我喜欢那个。它们不见了。我当时就像，好吧，那家伙有个很棒的快球。嘿，你，你做这个已经很久了。你一直在做脱口秀和播客，
and without missing a beat, Andy shrieked, my pearls. And I was just like, this classic sort of Merck's brothers, three Stooges, my pearls. I love that. They're gone. And I was just like, okay, that guy's got a great fastball. Hey, what do you, you've been doing this for so long. You've been doing a talk show and a podcast
看起来你从来没有停止采访某人或处于那个世界中。还有什么你想做的吗？还是你正在做，或者你只想余生一直做这个？嗯，我不认为你能说，我想一直做这个。它一直在变化和演变。
and it seems like you're never not interviewing somebody or in that world. Is there anything else you wanna do or you're doing it or do you wanna just keep doing this for the rest of your life? Well, I don't think you can ever say, I wanna keep doing this. It just keeps changing and evolving.
我想当时间到了，我认为演艺圈已经变了。过去你必须说，好吧，再见，人们过去常宣布，想想看，现在不是1992年，约翰尼·卡森说，好吧，就这样，再见，告别，向美国挥手告别。然后字面上乘着一束光升起，
And I think when it's time to, I think show business has changed. It used to be that you had to say, well, farewell, and people used to announce like, think of, it's not 1992, Johnny Carson says, well, that's it, goodbye and farewell and waves goodbye to America. And then literally ascends on a beam of light
骑着独角兽走向日落。而现在我觉得——那只是为了我。那是为了你。你是今天唯一拥有卡森地位的人。但不，我只是觉得我对那个问题的回答是我喜欢创造东西。我知道当我，如果我参与了一些
and rides a unicorn into the sunset. And now I feel like- That's just for me. That's for you. You're the only one that has Carson's stature today. But no, I just feel like my answer to that is I like to make things. And I know when I'm, if I'm involved in something
我不喜欢做的事情，我有奢侈的权利说，你知道，这感觉不好，我不想做这个。但如果我喜欢某件事，我喜欢做它，而且我很享受它，那么我会继续做下去。我不知道什么时候会结束。所以它可能只是不断变形。我是说，我确实认为随着互联网和我们现在所处的世界，
I don't like to do, I have the luxury of saying, you know, this doesn't feel good and I don't wanna do this. But if I like something and I like to do it and I'm enjoying it, then I'll keep doing it. And I don't know when that runs out. So it may just keep morphing. I mean, I do think with the internet and with the world we're in now,
五年内会有1亿个脱口秀。所以并不是，我不是为了谦虚才这么说，但如果我明天消失了，不再做节目，美国也不会有戒断反应。不会有那种，嗯，那发生了，因为外面有太多东西了。有太多的更替。但另一件事是他们不再对任何人或任何事有戒断反应了。
there'll be 100 million talk shows within like five years. So it's not like, and I'm not saying this to be humble, but if I went away tomorrow and wasn't doing a show, America would have no withdrawal. There'd be no like, well, that happened because there's so much out there. There's so much turnover. But the other thing is they have no withdrawal
所以没有，一切都太一次性了。所以你制作了相当多的东西，或者你长期拥有一家制作公司，你制作了各种各样的东西。你看到，而且你和杰夫·罗斯制作了很多东西，对吧？他是你的合伙人。
from anybody or anything anymore. So there's no, everything's so disposable. And so you produce quite a lot of stuff or you've had a production company for a long time and you've produced various things. Do you see, and you produce a lot of stuff with Jeff Ross, right? He's your partner.
是啊，是啊。顺便问一下，那种关系怎么样？所以你们开始，他是节目的制片人。你们之前认识吗？不，洛恩把我们放在一起。洛恩·迈克尔斯，我坐在现场，他是那个人。他说，你将和杰夫·罗斯一起工作。所以杰夫·罗斯是我与之搭档的人，
Yeah, yeah. What's that relationship like, by the way? So you guys started, he was the producer of the show. Did you guys know each other before? No, Lorne put us together. Lorne Michaels, I've sat on it live, he was the one. And he said, you're gonna be working with Jeff Ross. And so Jeff Ross was the guy who I was sort of partnered
那是洛恩的安排。这就像花生酱，不是花生酱和果冻，有些东西没那么好。站起来，杰夫·罗斯，那个，那个，那个，不，不是那个杰夫·罗斯。那是杰夫·雷罗斯，他是烤肉大师。杰夫·罗斯是我们的执行制片人。
with, that's all Lorne. And it was just sort of peanut butter, not peanut butter and jelly, something not quite as good as that. Stand up, Jeff Ross, the, the, the, the, No, not that Jeff Ross. That's Jeff Reross and he's the roast master general. Jeff Ross is our executive producer.
是的，我们几乎一起做所有事情，而且它就是有效。他的，我的心率，我的静息心率大概是，你知道，225，而他的大概是每小时15次。他就像一只600年后还会活着的乌龟。所以有那样的心率，这也会进入你的社交生活吗？还是你发现你自动进入了相反的状态？
And yeah, he's, we sort of do everything together and it just works. His, my heart rate, my resting heart rate is like, you know, 225 and his is like 15 beats an hour. He's like a tortoise that will be alive in 600 years. So with that heart rate, does that go into your social life as well, or do you find that you kind of automatically click into the opposite?
换句话说，我整天都在做这个。我整天都在问问题。我整天都在想段子。现在当我出去和妻子还有另一对夫妇吃晚饭时，你发现你只是，本能地，你宁愿回答问题而不是问问题吗？比如，你怎么这么确定？
In other words, I've been doing this all day. I've been asking questions all day. I've been coming up with bits all day. And now when I go out to dinner with my wife and another couple, do you find that you just, instinctually, you just would rather answer questions than ask them? Like, how are you so sure?
不，我，我想我很难慢下来。我不断地，我一直都在做段子。我在镜子里做段子。没人的时候我也做段子。你的孩子们觉得你有趣吗？是啊，他们觉得。他们觉得。你知道，现在他们是青少年了，
No, I, I think I have a hard time slowing it down. I'm constantly, I do bits all the time. I do bits in the mirror. I do bits when no one's there. Do your kids think you're funny? Yeah, they do. They do. You know, now that they're teenagers,
笑话就是我很逊，我是个婴儿潮一代，是个白痴。我想那只会再持续40年，但你知道我的诀窍是什么吗？我实际上对我的九岁孩子说，我在过去两天内对我的九岁孩子说过，好吧，婴儿潮一代，对我的九岁孩子。我只是，我主动出击。没错，没错，没错。
that the joke is that I'm lame and I'm a boomer and an idiot. And I think that that's only gonna last another 40 years, but you know what my trick for that is, I actually say to my nine year, I've said to my nine year old within the last two days, okay, boomer to my nine year old. And I just, I go on the offensive with them. Right, right, right.
那非常好。那非常好。而且可能阻碍了你孩子真正的创造性成长。不是我，是他们。你妻子呢？她觉得你有趣吗？还是你必须，你发现你的素材只是？
That's very good. That's very good. And probably blocking some real creative growth for your child. It's not me, it's them. What about your wife? Does she think you're funny? Or do you have to, do you find that your material is just?
不，不，她是真心的，我可以真心地让她笑。她很棒。我们在一起20年了，结婚18年了，她仍然会笑，觉得我很有趣。我可以抓住她，因为这只是，她喜欢愚蠢的东西，但她会在浴室里听到我。就像我去刷牙，或者有时我晚上起来只是，你知道，
No, no, she's genuinely, I can genuinely make her laugh. She's great. We've been together 20 years, been married for 18 and she still laughs and finds me amusing. And I can get her cause it's just, she loves silly stuff, but she will hear me in the bathroom. Like I've gone to brush my teeth or sometimes I'll get up at night to like just, you know,
小便，然后我会，她会听到像，哦，你这么认为，嗯？你知道，她会像，什么？里面没人，那不是给任何人听的。而且我，它不会关掉。而且我，当我在《辛普森一家》时，有一个伟大的，伟大的辛普森编剧之一，迈克·里斯，曾经只是，当我做了一段很长的时间，
urinate and then I'll be, she'll just hear like, oh, you think so, eh? You know, and she'll be like, what? There's no one in there that's not for anybody. And I, it doesn't turn off. And I, when I was at the Simpsons, there's a great, one of the great Simpsons writers, Mike Reese, once just, when I had done like a long run
人们在房间里笑。他只是看着我，然后说，成为你会是什么样子？在晚上？这就像一枚导弹，它是什么，他不是想刻薄。他只是好奇，比如，当你试图冷静下来时，那种病理学是什么样的？
and people were laughing in the room. He just looked at me and he just went, what would it be like to be you? Like at night? And it was this missile that, and what does it, he wasn't trying to be mean. He was just curious, like, what's the pathology of that like when you're trying to calm down?
而且，它有时是有问题的。你知道，我有一个，我前几天，所以我有一个年幼的男婴。前几天，是昨天，我，他在哭。我抱着他走来走去，我女朋友，我能听到她从拐角处过来，所以我只是开始做这个段子，
And it, it's problematic at times. You know, I had, I had a, the other day, so I have a young baby boy. And the other day, it's yesterday, I was, he was sort of crying. I was holding it and walking around with him and my girlfriend, I could hear her coming around in the corner, so I just started doing this bit,
知道她最终会过来。但她以为，你在做什么？当她转过来时，我说，对吧？那个问题，你总是想找出是谁把狗放出来的？因为没人知道那是谁。我当时在拐角处很小声地做。她就像，你他妈在做什么？
knowing that she would eventually come up. But she thought like, what are you doing? And as she comes around, I'm going, right? And the question, you'll always want to find out who did let the dogs out? Because nobody knows who that was. And I was doing it really quietly around the corner. She was like, the fuck are you doing?
是啊，是啊，是啊。这是，这是一个段子，如果她没来，它本来会是一个给没人看的段子。它可能本来会是一个给一个人看的段子。但我理解同样的倾向，就是，你停不下来。是啊。我想对这次通话中的每个人说，
Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is, this is a bit for, if she hadn't come, it would have been a bit for none. And it was maybe gonna be a bit for one. But I understand that same inclination, which is like, you can't stop. Yeah. I want to say this about everybody on this call,
那就是我们都以某种方式存在，然后我们足够幸运找到了一个愿意付钱让我们保持那种方式的行业。是啊，当然。这就是我对它的感觉。不是，哦天哪，我们必须努力工作来扭曲自己，成为那个然后能进入那个行业的人。
which is we all were a certain way, and then we were lucky enough to find an industry that would pay us to be that way. Yeah, for sure. That's my feeling about it. It's not, oh my God, we've got to work so hard to contort ourselves to be the person who can then be in that industry.
我真的认为任何其他，我很谦虚，因为我想到整个人类历史，在人类历史的任何其他时刻，我的工作可能是在爱尔兰把一块石头从田地的一边搬到另一边。人们会讨厌我的。是啊，你会因为段子被解雇的。他不擅长这个。
I really do think any other, I'm very humble because I think of all of human history and in any other point in human history, my job would have been probably in Ireland to move a stone from one part of the field to the other. And people would have just hated me. Yeah, you would have gotten fired with bits. He's not good at it.
是啊，他花时间在头发上。他用猪排梳头。他是一个，那是一个经典的笑话。是啊，我不知道。你知道，你说得很有趣，因为我有，我的心率和你一样快，我想，而且我几乎一直处于高度焦虑中。我实际上找到了一份工作，
Yeah, he spends time on his hair. He's using a pork chop to comb his hair. He's being a, that's a classic joke. Yeah, I don't know. You know, it's interesting you say that, because I have, my heart rate is as fast as yours, I think, and I have, I'm high anxiety almost all the time. And I actually found a job
在我扮演的《威尔和格蕾丝》的角色中。那，所有的能量，那实际上是焦虑。我为它找到了一个出口。你知道，我只是碰巧找到了合适的角色来释放我所有的焦虑。所以人们就像，哦天哪，当你走进节目时，你精力充沛。而且你确实，你知道，像雪貂一样跳来跳去，
in the character I played on Will and Grace. That, all of that energy, that's actually anxiety. And I found an outlet for it. You know, I just happened to find the right part to let out all my anxiety. So people are like, oh my God, you so much energy when you come through the door on the show. And you do, you know, you jump around like a ferret,
像一只同性恋雪貂。我当时就像，是啊，你知道，那是我所有的焦虑。就像我不能，你知道，冷静下来。什么是《威尔和格蕾丝》？是啊，所以它，它是一个——等一下故事。为什么，你看，你知道吗，这就是为什么我认为我正在和两个伟大的自然主持人交谈。
like a gay ferret. And I'm like, yeah, you know, it's all my like anxiety. Like I can't, you know, calm down. And what is Will and Grace? Yeah, so it's, it's a- Just wait a minute for the story. Why, you see, you know what, and this is again, why I think I'm talking to two great natural hosts.
然后我也在和威尔交谈，你用你可恶的段子打断他们，它们是讽刺的，有一种油腻的酷。你有那种加拿大人，那里发生了很多事情。没人会附和那个。人们真的很喜欢肖恩，他们真的很喜欢，他们真的喜欢肖恩，他们，
And then I'm talking to Will as well, who you interrupt with your hateful bits and they're sarcastic and there's an oily kind of cool. You've got that Canadian, there's a lot of stuff going on there. And no one's gonna attach to that. People really like Sean and they really like, they really do, they like Sean and they,
不，我本来要说杰森的，但他们喜欢肖恩，他们感觉到了一种温暖，他们觉得杰森就像一个人。然后威尔，你从来不让任何人进来。我从来没见过你看着我的眼睛。你有玩偶的眼睛，玩偶的眼睛，玩偶的眼睛。
no, I was gonna get to Jason, but they like Sean, they feel a warmth there and they feel like Jason's like a human being. And then Will, you've just like, you never let anybody in. I've never seen you look me in the eye. You've got the eyes of a doll, a doll's eyes, a doll's eyes.
充满鲨鱼的眼睛，充满鲨鱼的眼睛。因为我不想让任何人看到这里面有多死寂。多死寂。但肖恩，但肖恩，你确实有，你也是一个高辛烷值的人。就像你不能，你从来不能坐着不动。是啊，我知道。
Full of shark eyes, full of shark eyes. Because I don't want anybody to see that how dead it is in here. How dead. But Sean, but Sean, truly you do have, you are like a high octane person as well. Like you can't, and you can't sit still ever. Yeah, I know.
嗯，你知道，我想说点什么，那就是，而且我认为我被听到是对的，终于在这个节目上有一点播出时间了。不，我至少得说一次话来赚那张支票，我想。但我吃了一顿饭，不久前，但在新冠疫情前和肖恩一起，斯科蒂在那里，我妻子也在那里。
Well, you know, I wanna say something, which is that, and I think I'm right to be heard, finally a little air time on this show. No, I have to speak once at least to earn the check, I guess. But I had a meal, not long ago, but pre-COVID with Sean, and Scottie was there and my wife was there.
而且是，我们都被付钱去做。那是一次付费露面。斯科蒂付钱，是啊，斯科蒂付钱。而且他也必须付钱给肖恩，这很奇怪。但他付钱给肖恩，他付钱给丽莎，他付钱给我。一切都会在洗涤中出来。是啊，随便吧。但不，我们吃了这顿饭，之后，
And it was, we were all paid to do it. It was a paid appearance. Scottie paid, yeah, Scottie paid. And he had to pay Sean as well, which was weird. But he paid Sean, he paid Liza, and he paid me. All comes out in the wash. Yeah, whatever. But no, we had this meal and afterwards,
笑声不断，真的很愉快。然后之后，我们就像开车回家。为什么，如果它像，它，你知道，只是评论。我忘了她具体是怎么说的，但就像，哦，看着你们两个，意思是两个同类，来自工厂同一部分，同一年制造的，
and lots of laughing and really delightful. And then afterwards, we're just like driving home. Why, if it's like, it's, you know, was just commenting. I forget exactly how she said it, but just like, oh, to watch the two of you, meaning two of the same kind, that came from the same part of the factory that were made the same year,
引擎相同，面对面，真的很有趣。我想，哦天哪，我也感觉到了。我觉得，哦，他脑子里有那种蜂鸟的东西。而且，是啊。像杰森和我这样的家伙，我们更酷，更真实。
that have the same engine in them, opposite each other is, it was really fun. And I thought, oh my God, I felt it too. I felt like, oh, he's got that hummingbird thing going on in his head. And, yeah. And guys like Jason and me, we're much, we're kind of cooler and realer.
是啊，完全。我们有那种真实。有点阴阳。但关于那个，比如你妻子，你发现是你的对立面。就像肖恩，和斯科蒂，他也是某种对立面。那是某种正确的平衡吗？
Yeah, totally. We kind of got that kind of real. Kind of yendy yang. But on that, like your wife, you find is the opposite of you. And like with Sean, with Scottie, he's sort of the opposite too. Is that sort of like the right balance?
绝对，是啊。我和阿曼达是相反的。阿曼达，她一分钟走一英里，我只是坐在那里，有点半，你知道，活着。我会偶尔扔一颗炸弹。只是挑选一些尖刻的话来说。我想这就是为什么我们都在长期关系中，对吧？
Absolutely, yeah. Where I'm the opposite with Amanda. Amanda, she goes a mile a minute and I just sit there kind of half, you know, alive. And I'll just, I'll throw a bomb every once in a while. Just kind of cherry pick some sort of snarky thing to say. I think that's why we're all in long-term relationships, right?
是因为它是阴阳。是啊，对吧。是啊。不，我想这就是为什么我们四个人都，你知道，非常成功。是啊，我知道，对吧？我告诉你一个有趣的，真实的故事，那就是艾米总是翻白眼，
Is because it's the yendy of the yang. Yeah, right. Yeah. No, I think why it's, it's why all four of us are well, you know, very successful. Yeah, I know, right? I'll tell you a funny, the true story, which is that Amy used to always roll her eyes
当柯南和我做段子时，她会生气，她会像，哦，她会像被我们胡闹搞得精疲力竭。然后当我在艾米和我分手后立刻见到柯南时，我们在比佛利山庄酒店碰到了。我们本来要谈论这个的。然后他回来，他就像，哦，谢天谢地，我们终于，她走了，我们终于可以做回我们自己了。
when Conan and I would do bits and she would get mad and she'd be like, oh, she'd be like exhausted by us fucking around. And then when I saw Conan right after Amy and I split up, we ran into each other at the Beverly Hills Hotel. We were going to talk about this before. And then he came back and he was like, oh, thank God, we can finally, she's gone and we can finally be ourselves.
我们可以做我们的段子。而且，你知道，我爱艾米，但她，你知道吗？我爱艾米，但她会，问题是有一些人我不能，我想我只是不能，我必须做段子。做段子，就像我第一次见到，是威尔，是啊，威尔。我第一次见到威尔，我以前从没见过他，我只从《发展受阻》里认识他。
We can do our bits. And, you know, I love Amy, but she, you know what? I love Amy, but she would, the problem is there are certain people who I cannot, and I think I just cannot be, I have to do bits. Do bits, like the first time I met, it's Will, yeah, Will. The first time I met Will, I'd never met him before and I just knew him from Arrested Development.
而且，你知道，每个人都在对那个节目赞不绝口，我去艾美奖，走进房间，在房间的另一头我看到了威尔，他在艾美奖后的州长舞会的大宴会厅的另一边。我看到他在房间的另一头，他看到了我，我们的目光锁定了。他开始慢慢撤退。
And it was, you know, everyone was raving about the show and I go to the Emmys and I walk into the room and way across the room I see Will and he's over on the other side of the big ballroom at the governor's ball after the Emmys. And I see him way across the room and he sees me in our eyes lock. He starts to slowly retreat.
我开始前进，然后他在跑，我在后面追他。哦天哪，我做过那个段子一百万次了。是啊，而且就像——而且我们从没见过面。我们从没见过面。而且有像你这样的人，30号大楼著名的杰克·麦克布莱尔，我这辈子从来没有过一个真正的，
I start to advance and then he's running and I'm running after him. Oh my God, I've done that bit a million times. Yeah, and it's like- And we've never met. We've never met. And there are people like you, Jack McBrayer of 30 Rock fame, I've never in my life had a real,
每当我看到，而且我认识杰克15年了，他是个可爱的人，但每当他来节目时，当我们在洛克菲勒中心录制节目时，他会像只是过来，我立刻进入，嗯，嗯，嗯，乡村，我变成了城市滑头混蛋，而他是乡村土包子。我会说，我不知道他们把屎堆得那么高，男孩，他会表现得真的很受伤，说，
whenever I see, and I've known Jack for 15 years and he's a lovely guy, but whenever he would come by the show, when we taped the show in Rock For Our Center, he'd like just come by and I'd immediately go into, well, well, well, country, and I'd become the city slicker asshole to his country bumpkin. And I'd be like, I didn't know they stacked shit that high, boy, and he would get act real hurt and go,
现在，先生，你停下，我说，你在电梯里害怕了吗？因为房间动了。所以发生的事情是人们会，他参与其中，因为他完全在扮演那个角色，先生，我愤恨你认为我从来没写过它，你知道，但其他人，我们太投入了，以至于剧组有一次和我谈话，说，
now, sir, you stop and I go, did you get scared in the elevator? Cause the room moved. And so what happened was people would, he was in on it, cause he was totally playing the part of, sir, I resent that you think I've never written in it, you know, but everyone else, we committed to it so much that the crew had a talk with me at one point and said,
你知道吗，杰克是个好人，他过来做段子，而你对待他的方式。我当时就像，什么？我告诉了杰克·麦克布莱尔，他在嚎叫，但直到今天，我想如果，如果杰克发生了可怕的车祸，或者反之亦然，如果我发生了可怕的车祸，杰克在医院看望我，我当时插着管子，
you know what, Jack's a good guy and he comes by and he does bits and the way, and the way you treat him. And I'm like, what? And I told Jack McBrayer and he was howling, but to this day, I think if, if Jack was in like a terrible car accident or vice versa, if I was in a terrible car accident and Jack visited me in the hospital and I was there with tubes going into me,
我去了，你好，他会叫我奥布莱恩先生，说，你好啊，奥布莱恩先生。我当时会，字面上在生命维持系统上，我会，我会像，嗯，嗯，你把你的驴放在急诊室了吗？你的驴在急诊室吗，乡村小伙？他会说，先生，我不欣赏，你知道。柯南，你曾经指责我，
I went, hello, he'd call me Mr. O'Brien and go, hello there, Mr. O'Brien. And I'd be on, literally on life support and I'd be, I'd go like, well, well, where'd you put, did they let your donkey in the ER? Is your donkey in the ER there, countryfeller? And he'd go, sir, I don't appreciate, you know. Conan, you accuse me once of the,
如果你在中国中间，你需要帮助，你遇到了我，我只会做一个段子而不帮你。所以，我会跟着段子走。你会跟着段子走，而且是，你知道什么是疯狂的，其中一些东西我们会保留，一些我们不必，但什么是疯狂的是当我进去做30号大楼，
if you were in the middle of China and you needed help and you ran across me that I would just do a bit and not help you. So, and I would go along with the bit. And you'd go along with the bit and be, you know what's crazy and some of this stuff we will keep in some we don't have to, but what's crazy is when I went in and I'm doing 30 rock
而且我认识杰克多年了，因为他过去，他一直在UCB，而且他，你知道，他开始在周日晚上做Ascat等等。所以我认识他，而且我，我们一直有类似的对抗关系。就像我会看到麦克布莱尔，就像，天哪，什么？麦克布莱尔，他妈的什么，你知道，所以我把它带到片场。
and I'd known Jack for years, cause he used to, he was at UCB all the time and he, you know, he started doing Ascat on Sunday nights and whatever. So I knew him and I, we had a similar sort of fo adversarial relationship always. Like I'd see McBrown be like, Jesus, what? McBrown, what the fuck, you know, so I take it to set.
所以我们在片场，亚历克在那里，然后杰克来到片场，我当时就像，哦，他妈的杰克在里面。好吧，就像，你知道，随便。而且像卡洛斯在那里，那些家伙，我在胡闹。亚历克对我说，嘿，你知道，杰克很敏感。你可能想轻松点。
So we're on set and Alec is there and then Jack comes on to set and I'm like, oh, fucking Jack's in this. Okay, like, you know, whatever. And like Carlos there and those guys and I'm fucking around. And Alec says to me, hey, you know, Jack's very sensitive. You might want to take it easy.
我当时就像，不，不，不，不，不，伙计，我搞定了。你，我很好。我告诉，我，我几年前，那是威尔·法瑞尔在《周六夜现场》待了，我不知道，也许两年，三年。而且他，他的明星正在上升。他很有名，而且他真的开始点击了。
And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, man, I got this. You're, I'm all good. I told, I, I got on a years and years ago and it was when Will Ferrell had been on Saturday Night Live for like, I don't know, maybe two years, three years. And he was, his star was on the rise. He was well known and he was really starting to click.
我不得不坐飞机。我想是从洛杉矶到纽约或纽约到洛杉矶的某个地方，我上了飞机，坐在我的座位上，我认识威尔只是因为他有时会下来做段子，他字面上会在《周六夜现场》。那是周中，他会有一个段子的想法。他会下来，他说，我有这个家伙的想法，我们会像，太棒了，我们会做。
And I had to take a flight. I think it was from LA to New York or New York to LA somewhere and I get on the flight and I sit in my seat and I knew Will just because he would sometimes come down and do bits, he'd literally be up at Saturday Night Live. It's the middle of the week, he'd have an idea for a bit. He'd come down, he'd say, I have this idea of this guy and would be like, great and we'd do it.
而且它会很搞笑。所以这是，你知道，在他甚至作为嘉宾出现之前，他会为我们做这些段子。所以威尔，威尔·法瑞尔坐在我旁边的座位上，完全是偶然。我说，哦，天哪，嘿，嘿，嘿，几秒钟内。我在做一个段子。我膝盖上有一本大书，我当时就像，啊，书，
And it would be hilarious. So this was, you know, before he was even on much as a guest, he would do these bits for us. So Will, Will Ferrell sits down in the seat next to me, just total chance. And I go, oh, hell, hey, hey, hey, within seconds. I'm doing a bit. I had a big book in my lap and I was like, ah, books,
我一直在摩擦那本书，他会去，然后他只是进入了即兴表演，哦，你喜欢，哦，书，书，书，我生命中的书，威尔，书。这是一个关于他和我谈话越多，就越清楚我甚至不会读书的整个段子。我从来没读过书，而且我在过度补偿。飞机，正如你们所知，是五个半小时的飞行。我从来，从来没问过他，你好吗？
and I kept rubbing the book and he'd go, and then he just went into the improv thing of, oh, you like, oh, books, books, books of my life, Will, books. And it was a whole bit about how the more he talked to me, the more it became clear that I can't even read. That I've never read a book and I'm overcompensating. The flight, as you all know, is a five and a half hour flight. I never, ever asked him, how are you?
是啊。他从来没问过我，你结婚了吗？这是什么？整个事情就像，但书。然后他会起来走到后面，那，你知道，然后我在倒着读它。他说，你知道，你可能想翻到，别跟我说话。
Yeah. He never asked me, are you married? What's this? The whole thing was like, but books. And then he'd get up and come to the back and that, you know, and then I'm reading it upside down. And he's saying, you know, you might wanna turn to the, don't you talk to me.
那太有趣了。这很有趣，但有什么不对劲。但他没问你，他没问你是否结婚。他可能以为你是个坚定的单身汉。那大概就是那回事，对吧？你当时，确定你是个单身汉。我过去常非常公开地露面，
That's so funny. It's funny, but there's something wrong. But he didn't ask you, he didn't ask you to be married. He probably thought you were a confirmed bachelor. That was kind of the thing, right? You were, it was confirmed that you were a bachelor at the time. I used to make very public appearances
和蒂比·海德伦一起，会有照片之类的。但当你遇到那样的人时，有一种很好的舒适感。有一种很好的熟悉感，对吧？我想是的。有一种，你知道，它……我想我们都是那方面的同道中人。重点是，我们都有这样的朋友。
with Tippi Hedrin and there'd be photographs and stuff. But there's a nice coziness when you meet somebody like that. There's a nice familiarity, right? I think so. There's like, you know, it's... I think we're all kindred spirits in that. And the thing is it's, we all have friends like this too.
这不是什么演艺圈俱乐部。世界上有无数人碰巧不在演艺圈，他们是骨科医生，或者，你知道，他们做景观设计，或者他们，你知道，他们开垃圾车，他们做同样的事情。这是一种我真的很喜欢的精神，人们只是，而且你感觉到了。
This is not like some show business club. There's a million people out there in the world who don't happen to be in show business who are orthopedic surgeons or, you know, they landscape or they, you know, they drive a trash truck and they do the same thing. It's a kind of spirit that I really love are people that are just, and you pick it up.
我是说，我做过，我们都像，你在好市多之类的，就像我去过好市多。抱歉，我不能卖那个。嗯，这就是播客，伙计们。就这样。那是最后一个词。我住在一座金房子里。总之。
I mean, I've done, we've all like, you've been at a Costco or something like I've been to a Costco. I'm sorry, I can't sell that. Well, that's the podcast guys. That's it. That's the last word. I'm living in a house made of gold. Anyway.
我的意思是，我做过，我们都像，你去过好市多之类的，我也去过好市多。抱歉，我不能卖那个。好吧，这就是播客的内容了，伙计们。就这样。这是最后一句话。我住在一座金子做的房子里。总之。
Wait, I have a quick... No, no, I want to break in for a second and bring up a point here, which is that I happen to know for a fact that Will Arnett only flies private and did long before he could afford it. He has his own plane and this is a true story. Two years ago, he had the Rolling Stones tongue logo painted on the back of the plane,
等等，我有个简短的……不，不，我想打断一下，提个观点，我碰巧知道一个事实，威尔·阿奈特只坐私人飞机，而且在他买得起之前很久就开始这么做了。他有自己的飞机，这是个真实的故事。两年前，他在飞机尾部喷绘了滚石乐队的舌头标志，
which is just fucking confusing. Why would you, it's confusing. People think the Rolling Stones are in town and then you get off the plane and people are like, oh yeah, from the show and the voice of the truck. But why, why did you do that? The voice of the truck. Voice of the truck.
这简直太他妈让人困惑了。你为什么要这么做？这很让人困惑。人们以为滚石乐队到城里来了，然后你下了飞机，人们就会说，哦，是那个节目和那个卡车的声音。但为什么，你为什么要那样做？卡车的声音。卡车的声音。
But why did you do that? Why did you feel the need to do that? Here's the thing. First of all, you know I'm a huge Stones fan. I've never disguised that. I've always been really upfront. I love, ever since I saw Apocalypse Now, that was the first time I heard him.
但你为什么要那样做？你为什么觉得有必要那样做？是这样的。首先，你知道我是滚石乐队的超级粉丝。我从来没有掩饰过这一点。我一直都很坦率。我热爱，自从我看了《现代启示录》，那是我第一次听到他们的歌。
And then I was a big, I saw them. That's the doors. And I saw the Steel Wheels tour was the greatest Stones tour. I don't know if you guys happen to see the Steel Wheels. You know what, Steel Wheels is their best album. Is their best album. And I saw them in 1993 at Sky Dome in Toronto.
然后我成了大粉丝，我看了他们的演出。那是大门乐队。我看了“钢铁轮子”巡演，那是滚石最棒的巡演。我不知道你们有没有看过“钢铁轮子”。你知道吗，“钢铁轮子”是他们最好的专辑。是他们最好的专辑。我1993年在多伦多的天穹体育场看了他们的演出。
I saw them at Sky Dome. I don't know if you've ever been there. Incredible place to see. You want to talk about ambiance. So that's why I did that. And also I got, the Rolling Stones asked me to paint it on my plane. Is that true?
我在天穹体育场看了他们。我不知道你有没有去过那里。那是个看演出的绝佳地方。你想谈谈氛围的话。所以我才那么做。而且，滚石乐队还邀请我把标志画在我的飞机上。那是真的吗？
That's a true story. Mick Jagger. Wait, are you kidding me? No, so Keith Richards owed me $11 million because I had gone into receivership. Okay, so you know in the Palisades, if you're going west on Sunset. Yes.
那是真实的故事。米克·贾格尔。等等，你在开玩笑吗？不，基思·理查兹欠我1100万美元，因为我破产了。好吧，你知道在帕利塞德，如果你在日落大道上向西走。是的。
That's the part of every story where you know it's a lie. Whenever someone's going says like, okay, wait a minute. You know when you're in the Palisades and you're going west on Sunset, then you know because when they were interrogating Oswald, there was about 28 hours before Oswald's killed when they have him in custody.
那是每个故事里你一听就知道是谎话的部分。每当有人说，好吧，等一下。你知道当你身处帕利塞德，在日落大道上向西走的时候，你就知道，因为当他们在审讯奥斯瓦尔德时，在奥斯瓦尔德被杀前大约有28小时，他们把他关押起来。
And he was like, I didn't do it. I didn't do it. I didn't do it. And they put you work in the building. You bought the gun. And at one point he went, you know when you're in the Palisades going west on Sunset and that's when they knew they had him.
他当时说，我没做，我没做，我没做。他们说你就在那栋楼里工作。你买了枪。有一次他说，你知道当你身处帕利塞德，在日落大道上向西走的时候，就在那时他们知道抓到他了。
And just then Jack Ruby shot him. And so that's a fact too. That's a golden, that's a fact. That's a fact. Conan out of, really out of left field. Did you always want to go to Harvard? Was it a fair, complete that you were going to get into Harvard?
就在那时杰克·鲁比开枪打死了他。所以这也是个事实。那是金句，那是事实。那是事实。柯南，真的太出人意料了。你一直想去哈佛吗？你一定能进哈佛是板上钉钉的事吗？
Was it like a done deal? Did you? How could it be a done deal? How could it? I don't know. Like did you, did you have, I thought about it. Did you have crazy good grades?
就像是已经定好的事？你吗？怎么可能是定好的事？怎么可能？我不知道。就像你，你有，我考虑过。你的成绩好到离谱吗？
No, I was the, you know, so funny because I get this reputation as, oh, you went to Harvard. So you just- No, that's not out there. Yeah. Never heard that. Yeah. And people think, oh, you were just really smart.
不，我是那个，你知道，很有趣，因为我有了这种名声，哦，你上了哈佛。所以你只是——不，那不是真的。是的。从来没听说过。是的。人们以为，哦，你只是真的很聪明。
And I think, wow, my experience of being a kid was no one in my family, my parents are very smart people, but no one had gone to Harvard college. And I was in the middle of the family and I was very anxious. I had a lot of anxiety and I decided, I think around the fourth or fifth grade, I've just got to be a great student.
我想，哇，我小时候的经历是，我家里没有人，我父母是很聪明的人，但没有人上过哈佛学院。我在家里排行中间，我非常焦虑。我有很多焦虑，我想大概在四五年级的时候，我决定，我必须成为一名优秀的学生。
And so I was a grind. I was, it was nothing funny about it. I was funny with my friends, but then I would take impeccable notes. I would go up to my little room in the attic and I would grind and I ground my way in. And I just decided I'm going, I didn't know exactly that I was going to Harvard,
所以我很刻苦。我，那一点也不好玩。我和朋友在一起时很有趣，但我会做完美的笔记。我会回到阁楼上的小房间里，刻苦钻研，我就是这样钻研进去的。我只是决定我要去，我并不确切知道我要去哈佛，
but then when I got in, I thought, okay, I'm going there. And it was only when I got there that I realized, oh, they've got this comedy magazine that's seminal and amazing, the lampoon. And I went, that was just like a, that was not the reason for going there, but that's what changed my life. So I was a total grind who ended up working really hard
但当我被录取时，我想，好吧，我要去那里。直到我到了那里，我才意识到，哦，他们有这本开创性且令人惊叹的喜剧杂志，《哈佛讽刺家》。我去了，那并不是去那里的原因，但那改变了我的人生。所以我是一个彻底的苦行僧，最终非常努力地
to get into this great college and then found comedy by doing that. And so that was, it's kind of a weird show, entrance into show business, I think, when you think about it. What did you think you were going to study there? When I got there, I studied, I was a pretty serious student. I studied history and literature of America,
考进了这所伟大的大学，然后通过做那个发现了喜剧。所以，当你仔细想想，这进入演艺圈的方式有点奇怪。你当时想在那里学什么？当我到那里时，我学习，我是一个相当认真的学生。我学习美国的历史和文学，
but I thought I'd be either a very serious writer or I'd get into government. And I'd probably get a law degree and I just, I would follow some kind of track. And it was only, I mean, I knew immediately when people on the lampoon sort of said to me when I was 18 and they were 21 or 22, you're a very funny young fellow. That meant a lot to me and that changed my life.
但我以为我会成为一名非常严肃的作家，或者进入政府部门。我可能会拿到法律学位，我会走某种轨道。直到，我的意思是，当我在18岁时，那些在《讽刺家》的人，他们当时21或22岁，对我说，你是个非常有趣的年轻人。那对我意义重大，那改变了我的人生。
I didn't, I thought, I knew I was a funny guy with my friends, but suddenly people that seemed like full grown adults to me who were headed off into the world were telling me, you've got something, kid. And that just changed everything for me. So that's cool. Same. So.
我没有，我想，我知道我和朋友在一起时是个有趣的人，但突然间，那些在我看来已经是完全成熟的成年人，即将走向世界的人，告诉我，孩子，你很有天赋。那对我来说改变了一切。所以那很酷。我也是。所以。
I used to run into you at Harvard. I remember that. Yeah, all the time. I loved her. I used to, man, it was so good and just around with all the buildings and stuff. And it was so cool. You know, I didn't think you went,
我过去常在哈佛碰到你。我记得那个。是的，一直都是。我爱她。我过去常，天哪，那太棒了，就在所有的建筑周围转悠之类的。那太酷了。你知道，我没想到你去了，
when you mentioned buildings, I knew that you had sealed the deal. Only you knew about it. What dorm did you stay in? John F. Kennedy International Center for Dormitories. Man, it was unbelievable. Again, I'll take your word for it. No, arguing with this guy.
当你提到建筑时，我就知道你已经搞定了。只有你知道这件事。你住在哪个宿舍？约翰·F·肯尼迪国际宿舍中心。天哪，那真是不可思议。再说一次，我信你的话。没人能跟这家伙争论。
No, I do wish one thing, which is, I mean, I'm very proud that I went there and I worked hard and I met a lot of really amazing people. And, but I wish no one knew because I do think there are times on the talk show over the years where people can just say, well, I didn't go to Harvard and you just feel like, oh, shit. Like, I don't know.
不，我确实希望一件事，那就是，我的意思是，我很自豪我去了那里，我努力工作，我遇到了很多非常了不起的人。但是，我希望没人知道，因为我觉得在脱口秀节目中，多年来人们有时会说，好吧，我没上过哈佛，你就会觉得，哦，该死。就像，我不知道。
I think suddenly that maybe that's off-putting to other people and I know because I went there that like any other school, it's a very flawed place. I met some very smart people, some incredibly stupid people. And yeah. Well, there are a lot of people who lead with it, right? That's sort of their thing that they, of course, for the rest of their life.
我想突然间这可能会让其他人感到反感，我知道因为我去了那里，就像任何其他学校一样，它是一个有很多缺陷的地方。我遇到了一些非常聪明的人，也遇到了一些极其愚蠢的人。是的。嗯，有很多人以此为傲，对吧？那是他们的一种特质，他们，当然，余生都这样。
With a question mark at the end of it, though. I went to Harvard. Harvard? Yeah, like we don't know. Well, so I didn't go, but my dad went to Harvard and he never talks about it or he never mentions it. Right. And it's just not a thing that he-
不过结尾带个问号。我上了哈佛。哈佛？是的，好像我们不知道一样。嗯，所以我没去，但我爸爸上了哈佛，他从不谈论它，或者他从不提起它。对。那根本不是他会……
That's the first time I've heard of that. Yeah, yeah. You know, what's interesting is I went to First Lady Michelle Obama had some event to get kids to really get excited about registering for college or trying to go to college. And she had this event and she asked a lot of people and I was one of them.
这是我第一次听说。是的，是的。你知道，有趣的是，我去了第一夫人米歇尔·奥巴马举办的一个活动，目的是让孩子们真正对注册大学或尝试上大学感到兴奋。她举办了这个活动，她邀请了很多人，我也是其中之一。
I'm sure I was the first call, but there wasn't a call sheet but I would have been pretty high. But she asked a lot of people to show up at UCLA and do this thing. And she said, oh, and everyone wear your, a sweatshirt from your college. Like that'll be a fun thing. And I just couldn't, I can never do that.
我敢肯定我是第一个被邀请的，虽然没有名单，但我肯定排得很靠前。但她邀请了很多人到加州大学洛杉矶分校参加这个活动。她说，哦，每个人都穿上你们大学的运动衫。那会很有趣。但我就是做不到，我永远做不到。
So I didn't. I just wore a jean jacket and a shirt. You wore a sweatshirt from college, from when you went there. You're supposed to wear a, or just, or if you don't have it, go out and buy one. You're supposed to wear, and I just didn't,
所以我没穿。我只是穿了件牛仔夹克和衬衫。你穿了你上大学时的运动衫。你应该穿一件，或者如果你没有，就去买一件。你应该穿，但我就是没穿，
you know, obviously I don't wanna walk, I'm not gonna walk around. I spent, it's funny. I worked so hard to get into the place and then I got in and then I graduate. And the minute I graduated, I started backtracking on that's where I went to school. It's amazing that if Jason and Gunny
你知道，显然我不想走来走去，我不会走来走去。我花了，很有趣。我努力工作才考进那个地方，然后我进去了，然后我毕业了。我毕业的那一刻，我就开始回避我是在那里上的学。令人惊奇的是，如果杰森和甘尼
and his sweatshirt were to set Teen Wolf two. Yeah. Teen Wolf two you. You know. Teen Wolf two you. So. That stigma you talk about of having Harvard on your back, you know, it's,
还有他的运动衫去拍《狼少年2》。是的，《狼少年2》你。你知道。《狼少年2》你。所以。你谈到的那种背负着哈佛名声的耻辱感，你知道，它是，
I know what you mean. Like, so what is it makes you feel extra pressure that you don't want? You know, because would you have felt the same way if you went to a state school? No, I don't, I mean, I don't know. I can't answer that question. I just think it gets, I don't like,
我知道你的意思。就像，是什么让你感到不想承受的额外压力？你知道，如果你上的是州立大学，你会有同样的感觉吗？不，我不知道，我的意思是，我不知道。我无法回答那个问题。我只是觉得它变得，我不喜欢，
I hate being put in any kind of box in any way. Even if it's a box that other people would think, oh, I would love to be in that box. I resent it. And I know that sounds strange because there are probably a lot of people out there that think like, well, that's a good thing that you went there.
我讨厌以任何方式被贴上任何标签。即使是别人认为，哦，我很乐意被贴上的标签。我也很反感。我知道这听起来很奇怪，因为可能有很多外面的人会想，好吧，你能去那里是件好事。
And I am proud of it, but I remember before when I was announced as this guy named Conan O'Brien is going to replace David Letterman. And everyone's wondering who is this guy? All they knew about me is that I had gone to Harvard and I kept reading, oh, so it's going to be this urbane. Right. You know.
我确实为此感到自豪，但我记得以前当我被宣布为这个叫柯南·奥布莱恩的人将要接替大卫·莱特曼时。每个人都在想这家伙是谁？他们对我唯一的了解就是我上了哈佛，我一直读到，哦，所以这将是这个文雅的。对。你知道。
It's like you can't be funny and have a six pack. Exactly. This is Will's problem. Oh yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. Check this out. Conan, when do you think that you're going to get into comedy?
就像你不能既有趣又有六块腹肌一样。正是如此。这是威尔的问题。哦，是的。是的。哦，是的。看看这个。柯南，你觉得你什么时候会进入喜剧界？
Yeah. Like when do you think that will happen? A good question. Well, cause you talk a lot about it. Well, I've been a long time fan and it's just working up the nerve to just say, I think I'm ready and to go ahead and do it. And just say like, do it.
是的。就像你觉得那什么时候会发生？好问题。嗯，因为你经常谈论它。嗯，我一直是个老粉丝，只是在鼓起勇气说，我想我准备好了，去继续做这件事。就说，去做吧。
And I was like, hang on, I'm going to write down a couple of numbers. I know some people that you can call. Okay. And then you can just, you know. Okay. Give him a call. Okay.
我说，等一下，我要写下几个号码。我认识一些你可以打电话的人。好的。然后你就可以，你知道。好的。给他打个电话。好的。
This is fantastic. I really appreciate this. Of course, dude. You're such a good guy. Now who is, I'm looking at the, who is Richard kind? I'm supposed to call Richard kind? God, I love him. By the way.
这太棒了。我真的很感激。当然，伙计。你真是个好人。现在谁是，我在看，谁是理查德·金？我应该给理查德·金打电话？天哪，我爱他。顺便说一句。
I love Richard kind. He's a perfect dude. A perfect dude. 818. 818. Lives deep in the valley. I'll call this Richard kind, but I want to do it. And I think I'm ready to do it.
我爱理查德·金。他是个完美的人。完美的人。818。818。住在山谷深处。我会给这个理查德·金打电话，但我想要去做。而且我觉得我准备好去做了。
So I, you know, the nice thing is you guys encouraging me. That's the nice thing. He's got two numbers. He's got 818 and he's also in New York. He's also 718. So he's 818. Okay. He's never at the center of things.
所以我，你知道，好的一点是你们鼓励我。那是好的一点。他有两个号码。他有818，他在纽约也有。他也有718。所以他是818。好的。他从不在事情的中心。
Is he? No. I feel like we're being real greedy with him. Yeah. We're being greedy with our time. Conan, you've been so generous. Incredibly kind of you. Listen, I, I'm going to be very honest with you.
是吗？不。我觉得我们对他太贪心了。是的。我们在时间上太贪心了。柯南，你太慷慨了。你真是太好了。听着，我，我会对你非常诚实。
I try to avoid other podcasts like the plague. And then when they told me that you three had a podcast, I said, I will, I will pay to do that. That's so sweet. Three of the, no seriously. Three of the, of the funniest people I know and just getting to hang out with you guys was incredibly fun. And so thanks for having me.
我像躲避瘟疫一样避开其他播客。然后当他们告诉我你们三个有播客时，我说，我愿意付钱去做那个。那太甜了。三个，不，说真的。我认识的最有趣的三个，能和你们在一起真是太有趣了。所以谢谢你们邀请我。
I really mean that. Thank you, my friend. Very nice of you to say yes. You're a lovely people. So great having you. No, two of you, just to be here with, with Bateman and, and Sean to be, there's the two of you mean so much to me and there's one I'll never know.
我是真心的。谢谢你，我的朋友。你这么说真是太好了。是的。你们是可爱的人。有你们在真好。不，你们两个，能和贝特曼和肖恩在一起，你们两个对我意义重大，还有一个我永远不会认识。
And I don't think anyone will ever know him because he'd make a terrible host. He's unknowable. He's a shell with a voice. Well, I'm going to get out on that note. Thank you, Conan. We love you. Conan, we love you.
而且我不认为有人会认识他，因为他会是个糟糕的主持人。他是不可知的。他只是一个有声音的空壳。好吧，我就以此结束吧。谢谢你，柯南。我们爱你。柯南，我们爱你。
We thank you. Really fun, you guys. Thank you so much. That was, that was a joy. And I'll see you all later. Okay. That was fun. Goodbye, pal.
我们谢谢你。真的很有趣，伙计们。非常感谢。那真是，那真是种享受。我以后再见你们。好的。那很有趣。再见，伙计。
Thank you. Murderers, killers, murderers, murderers, murderers. That Conan, I do like that Conan. Me too. He's so funny. You know, I didn't want to get into the tonight's show stuff because I'm sure he's so sick of talking about it, but he was the best on that.
谢谢。谋杀犯，杀手，谋杀犯，谋杀犯，谋杀犯。那个柯南，我确实喜欢那个柯南。我也是。他太有趣了。你知道，我不想谈论今夜秀的事情，因为我肯定他已经厌倦了谈论它，但他在那方面是最棒的。
I mean, he was hilarious. God, he handled himself so well and that whole thing too, it was amazing. And I was thinking about it today before we did the show. I was thinking like we've all known him a long time and he was, you know, I got to know him from doing the show and we became friends and hung out a bunch and then he goes
我的意思是，他太搞笑了。天哪，他处理得太好了，整件事也是，太令人惊叹了。我在做节目之前今天还在想这件事。我在想，我们都认识他很久了，他，你知道，我是通过做节目认识他的，我们成了朋友，经常一起玩，然后他去
and he does the tonight show. And it was like such a great kind of crowning moment for him that he got given that gig. And then to have that whole thing kind of soured and kind of robbed from him in the way that it was was so particularly cruel. And I tell you, man, he handled it with such grace. And you know, the silver lining about all that
做了今夜秀。对他来说，能得到那个工作是一个伟大的加冕时刻。然后整件事以那种方式变质并被抢走，真是特别残忍。我告诉你，伙计，他处理得非常有风度。你知道，这一切的一线希望
is that you root for him. You just don't never stop rooting for him because of, not just because of that because he's brilliant, but you know, I just wish for him to continue succeeding because he deserves it. Same, same. Jason's not saying anything because Jason's not a fan.
就是你支持他。你永远不会停止支持他，不仅仅是因为那个，因为他很出色，但你知道，我只是希望他继续成功，因为他应得的。一样，一样。杰森什么也没说，因为杰森不是粉丝。
Yep. Yeah, no, I've got notes on him. I always have. Um, can we call him back? Yeah, yeah, that's gonna back up. No, I'm a huge fan of his. I'm glad what he said about how, because of the internet and what,
是的。是的，不，我有关于他的笔记。我一直都有。嗯，我们可以回拨给他吗？是的，是的，那会回拨的。不，我是他的超级粉丝。我很高兴他说关于因为互联网和什么，
like he's never going to go away. I love that there's like a guarantee that there's so much turnover in this business. And I love that he's not over it, that he doesn't run out of bits, that he's gonna be around forever. I love that. He is just a naturally funny guy.
就像他永远不会消失。我喜欢这种保证，在这个行业里有这么多的更替。我喜欢他没有过气，他不会用完段子，他会永远存在。我喜欢那个。他只是一个天生有趣的人。
Yeah, for sure. That's it. And he has no choice about it. For sure, yeah. It's not a skill. It's not a thing, a muscle. It's just that's- You just are, yeah.
是的，当然。就是这样。而且他别无选择。当然，是的。这不是一种技能。这不是一种东西，一种肌肉。只是那是——你就是，是的。
You just are. Yeah, I agree. And he is. And kind and personable. He's really kind. He's a perfect host. I love what he says he doesn't consider himself a host, but he's like, by definition,
你就是。是的，我同意。而且他是。善良且平易近人。他真的很善良。他是一个完美的主持人。我喜欢他说他不认为自己是一个主持人，但他就像，根据定义，
somebody you want to hang out with, even at your quietest moment in your home at night, you know, like 11, 30, like there's not a lot of people I want there, you know? Yeah, for sure. Okay, guys, so that was great, right? Having Conan on? One of the best ones.
一个你想和他在一起的人，即使在你家里最安静的夜晚，你知道，比如11点30分，你知道，没有多少人我想在那里，你知道吗？是的，当然。好吧，伙计们，所以那很棒，对吧？有柯南在？最好的之一。
So great, so great. Yeah, I mean, I could talk to him forever. I knew you guys would be excited about Conan. I love, yes, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great. What's his last name? I never caught it. I never caught it.
太棒了，太棒了。是的，我的意思是，我可以和他聊永远。我知道你们会为柯南感到兴奋。我爱，是的，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。他姓什么？我从来没听清。我从来没听清。
You don't need a last one when you got a first one like that. When your name's Conan? Right? Yeah. I remember when he first came on, everyone was like, is it Conan or Conan? Yeah.
当你有一个那样的名字时，你不需要姓。当你的名字是柯南时？对吧？是的。我记得他刚来的时候，每个人都在问，是柯南还是柯南？是的。
I do remember that. No one knew how to pronounce it. I still sometimes do it when I go on a show, I'll go, I'll go, well, good to see you, Conal. And he'll go, it's Conan. I go, it is? I've done that, I've done that to him a bunch of times. What? That's your name?
我确实记得那个。没人知道怎么发音。我有时去参加节目时还会那样，我会说，嗯，很高兴见到你，科纳尔。他会说，是柯南。我说，是吗？我对他那样做过好几次。什么？那是你的名字？
Conan with an N? Conal. What? Wow. Okay. Good guess, Willie. Thanks, boys. Great episode.
柯南带个N？科纳尔。什么？哇。好吧。好猜测，威利。谢谢，伙计们。很棒的一集。
Hey, listen, I guess it goes without saying, but... Bye-bye. Smart. Last. Smart. It was all good. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嘿，听着，我想不用说也知道，但是……再见。聪明。最后。聪明。一切都很好。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。